Oh, well, well, give me a sec.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Today has been quite a shitty day.
So I was like, you know what would make this day even worse?
If I doom queue again in Marvel Rivals on stream.
Yay.
So the reason why today has been a shitty day.
Yeah, the reason why today's been a shitty day was I usually, I'm starting my trial period with my new chef thing, like with my new like pre-cooked meal stuff, because I'm swapping pre-cooked meal providers, but she doesn't start until Wednesday.
So today I was ordering out for the first time in a while because I don't really order out that often ever since I started on pre-cooked meals to be healthier.
But so I was like, you know what?
I'm going to spoil myself.
I'm going to try this pizza place at this new restaurant.
I've never tried before because it seems to have good reviews.
So I ordered what said was their bestseller.
But the thing about their bestseller was that it had no description as to what the pizza was.
It just said it's really good.
So I was like, you know what?
It's their bestseller.
and all it doesn't even tell me what the ingredients by the way it doesn't even have the ingredients all the other pizzas had like exactly what the ingredients were but then this pizza was just like it's really good so i was like i trust that that's it seems really it says it's really good there's no pictures but like it said it's really good there's no way they're lying so it's like i haven't had pizza in like months so i was just like i'm gonna i'm gonna try it you know i haven't had reviews.
I even Googled it to make sure I looked at the pictures.
I was like, oh, these pizzas look good.
They look good.
It's like a dining pizza restaurant, too.
And the menu is no fancy.
You know, like a white menu with just no pictures and just font on it.
Like, just text on a white backing.
Like, that's when you know it's a fancy, fancy pizza restaurant because it's like pure Italian.
Pure Italia.
So I was just like, you know what?
I'm going to try it.
And then the pizza came and i realized oh it's italian italian as in there's no cheese on it it was literally just arugula and the parmaham and then a giant fucking slab of i don't know what the cheese called you know like the little the fluffy cheese like it's just a scoop of cheese look there is cheese but it's like a scoop of these the white fancy cheese just plop on top of it barada yeah just scooped up fucking john it's just a scoop of burrata on top of the pizza and then like arugula and pomeham i was just like it was so okay usually i like arugula and pomeham together but this one fucking sucked i was just like it was it's just it was just so bad i ate like two slices and i'm like no i can't i can't i'm not even gonna put it in the fridge that's how bad it is gonna put the rest of it in the i'm just gonna i i know like don't waste i can't i can't eat more of it i was just it was just so bad i was just not having it um so then yeah it was it was so bad that it doesn't i'm not
even gonna put it in the fridge i'm just it's just sitting there beside me right now anyway so yeah i was like i was like you know what i had a start of my bad day I'm gonna play rivals Like it can't get worse And I swear To God so you know how like I stream The ring sessions and I don't get I don't get yelled at you know I don't get yelled at or people being Passive aggressive but I swear to God I get yelled Or blamed less when I'm Streaming because they're fucking Scared They're fucking Cowers Pussies because they know I'm pretty shit these people know that if they're on stream their whole attitude changes um so like so like i was playing like i played three to four games and i had like two of them where people were being so fucking passive aggressive or like just pure like outright just mean and it's like i would say I did fuck up once but like but then like it was not me that sold the entire game and then so like okay so I was last game the last game I played um I was peeling
non-stop because the enemy team was playing like pure fucking dive so it was Angela Black Panther and Spider-Man and then I was peeling my other support 24 7 like I kept I just like I swapped the cloak because it was easier was invisible woman they break my shield um and then we're it's over for us so i like i like through my i swapped the cloak i threw my like bear like the circle heel thing and then um and then i just kept and then i like healed her not like healed her every time every time we got dope i held healed her 24 7 and then mag ulton i tied my cloak ability too early and then this bitch I can call it because she was such a fucking she was so fucking passive aggressive was like how did you die to the mag old like in chat like like oh my god and I'm like okay bitch like oh I was like wow I'm just like wow you're so unappreciative like What's that way when they're so unappreciative of everything I did for her?
So ungrateful.
I was like, wow, bitch.
So fucking ungrateful.
Yeah, she was so goddamn ungrateful.
And then she was the one that requested triple support.
So I went Ultron, like, during the second half.
And they're like, okay.
And then, like, and then the team played me for not swapping off Ultron.
And I'm just like, we all know I'm a support player.
Like, what do you want me to do?
I swap.
Because like, oh man, why are you Stokey?
Why are you still playing Triple Subart?
Swap off, I'll try.
And I'm just like, but I'm a support player.
I was literally playing support since the beginning.
Why don't you tell the other guy that swapped you the third support?
Like, I was just like, why blame me?
The other guy didn't even swap off support.
I would I picked support first Why is it my job to swap On support?
I don't play Take or DBS the other guy Was playing Take When did he win And then he went Luna Like why is it My fault?
If you want me To swap up Ultra I'd still be Playing another support and we still be Playing triple support Alright so I'm just like what I'm so confused so so I I figured if today people are gonna be like extra toxic assholes let's just expose them on stream I don't care I was like you know what if I'm getting these type of teammates today because I usually play rivals off stream because it's my off hours um but like it wasn't like it's never been like that I would get like someone like like once or like like once or something throughout the session but like today it's been like people are extra mean i think it's because it's a weekend so all the kids are back from school um because summer vacation is uh over so all the children are back um and i was just like i'm i swear to god you're gonna be passive aggressive or stupid to me right now i'm gonna show i'm i might as well be streaming this because i'm gonna farm you for content at that point like why why why am i not
monetize it if I'm going to be if I'm going to be bullied by children I'm going to monetize it kids you're you're going to be I'm going to use you for money I'm going to use you for money and content children if you're going to yell at me because I ain't doing I'm not getting yelled at by for free guys I'm I swear I'm not going to get yelled at for free I my this is my use of child labor i'm gonna farm the children uh so yeah basically long story short i'm so i got i'm sad because i ordered pizza and it was a shitty pizza and then i got bullied by children so i'm doom queuing and that's why i'm here today anyway before we go um we have three days left three days left Doki Bird X Gina draws Apparel Collab!
So, make sure to pre-order if you're looking forward to any of these items, any of these clothes and pajamas, eat the bags, hats, and all of this stuff.
Make sure to order it before the pre-order ends on the 24th and it's going to be gone forever!
Woo!
Well, it's not really a happy woo, but yeah!
You can do exclamation point collab and click on the link in the in the nightbot code thingy i don't fucking know in the in the shout out anyway all right let me give me a second i got a message i'm gonna be let me see what the message is real quick uh all right all right it's time maybe we'll fucking bump into someone to kidnap and drag them into my own personal hell this is my like so this is like one two three circles of hell in my seven circles of hell This takes up three of it.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I...
Wait, what happened to my...
What?
What happened?
No.
Why did they take it off?
I did not willingly took it off.
It has to be an update or some shit.
Because I would never take this off.
Wait, it is in it.
Wait, where is it?
I demand my twerk.
What?
Where did it go?
Why is it?
I equipped it.
Oh, is it because I zoomed up?
Oh, wait, no.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, you can't zoom in.
Oh.
I'm getting censored.
There's a censorship right there.
I...
Comic.
Thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
Why can't I zoom in on the chain?
Go on.
Fix this right now.
This is pure censorship.
Where is, yeah, where's my ethical gooning session?
All right, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna, wait, actually, no, my water's right there.
What am I saying?
I thought I thought my, I thought in that water.
Yeah, this is my Taka, thank you for tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
So yeah, I hope the games will be okay.
I just, I hope, I hope I don't crash out too much.
Actually, let's role play.
Let's role play with the, with the, with the, with the tweens.
All right.
Where, where is it?
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I'm so excited for the Daft Punk concert this week.
What is it?
It's on the 27th, right?
I'm so excited.
I can't wait.
Does anyone know what time it is?
Because I don't put it on the schedule.
Oh, this looks already promising.
God, this looks incredibly promising.
Yeah, there's going to be a Daft Punk Fortnite concert on the 27th.
8 p.m.
PSD or EST?
Or imaginary time?
In the eastern side.
Cloak and Darian.
I'm fucking banning Torch.
You don't decide what we ban.
That's so...
Oh, it's...
I was like, that's so late.
But then I'm like, oh, it's a Daft Punk concert.
So they want to be like...
It's because it's EDM.
So it has to be super late.
Because I'm not...
I'm not fucking raving out while the sun's still outside.
That's just...
That's just sad.
I'm gonna play strange after it, by the way.
And the sun's out and you're fucking in a rave.
Look at an angel and a blade.
Oh, oh, no, Medi's dumb.
Medi's fucking dumb.
Okay, never mind.
It is a morning rave.
Never mind, guys.
The raves in the morning.
Medi's just feeling like, um, today is 8 p.m.
right now.
Your hero.
Uh, angry.
Thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I guess I'll play Luna.
I shine in darkness.
Oh, spreading misinformation.
This early in the stream, Medi.
You're supposed to wait at the halfway point.
Also, this is my warm-up game.
I'm pretty slow today.
More slow than usual.
Also, Dad's at the dog sitter.
I'm giving him his, uh, I'm giving him his, like, holiday early.
Because I want to, I want to, I slept in.
Um, the dog sitter took him at 10.30 a.m.
And then I...
After I gave him to the dog sitter, I woke up at 4 p.m.
I need to catch up my sleep that I have a lot of sleep that I need to catch up on.
So I like, I gave him a...
Technically, I gave myself a three-day vacation.
That's not how it works.
I was just like, I need this.
All right.
He's been...
He's been a little too needy.
Oh, TP time.
I needed this.
Okay, I just realized I didn't adjust my rival's volume, so it might be super loud.
Oh my god, I missed.
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
I actually missed.
Guys, I told you this is a wormhole.
Oh my god, if I hit that he's dead.
I'm so sad I actually missed that.
I'm so sad.
That was actually so free I know guys I told you it was warm-up And also why did it require me to hit him?
There's six of us
There I killed him
At least.
Okay, I'm sorry the game's too loud.
I don't know what the volume is right now for this.
I actually didn't.
Wait, where?
Is this their side?
This is their side.
We have three sub- Oh.
It's my bad.
This is my bad.
That was such a bad play on you.
Yeah, no shit.
Like, you're our only take.
Oh.
We have Jeff.
Maybe if we're lucky, Jeff would like.
There you go.
You guys don't have anything.
Very, very careful.
Don't worry, I'm here.
We have an ult.
Alright!
There we go.
I did it!
Punisher, Punisher, Punisher, Punisher.
Please, I have to reload.
It can't just be me.
There we go.
I didn't miss, guys.
See, look at that.
Sorry about that, guys.
Okay, I was gonna say, are we really gonna let the Phoenix die?
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
they teleported oh they're teleporting we still have do you remember somebody called the hoary we still have invis up uh who yeah i think it should be turned down a little a h but i haven't died yet so that's awkward no one time i needed to die i'm just too good you know yes no he has blade out right there in this right okay we're definitely avoiding the blade god it's just i'm so i'm just so hard being so good at this game that i'm just not fit I can't die you know I just live forever one letter different man it's just so hard when you're just so good at the game he has all oh no I'm outside I'm outside but it doesn't matter there you go see it's easy Okay,
that was really stupid of me to go.
I thought he would like not see me.
That's why all right Let me fix this.
I just went straight.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It's very loud.
This is a lot louder than it's supposed to be I'm sorry The game is very loud Then what it should be I don't even know if we'll be able to see all right.
I'm trying to look I know it is louder.
Yeah
I hope it wasn't too loud.
I hope it wasn't too loud, yes.
I fixed it.
No, I just get on that account and, like, just think name works.
Uh, there you go.
What?
No.
It was that bad, thank God.
Yay.
Alright, I fixed it, though.
It was, like, three tiers higher than it should be.
It was, like, 11.0, and I usually put rivals at 15.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
This is why you don't stand in the portal right away.
This is exactly why, guys.
We stack.
Oh, nice.
Okay, we don't need a stack.
Okay, we just... Okay.
I guess we don't stack.
Guys, I guess we don't stack.
Oh, that's silly.
Silly me.
Silly me for thinking that we're a team.
That portal is so good at the start of every match.
Silly me.
I'm so stupid for thinking that.
For thinking this is a team game.
This is like everyone for themselves, right?
Oh, yep, that's right.
Oh, there's every man for themselves, stupid shark.
That's fucking right.
Please, please.
Oh, my God.
The only team player left in this lobby.
All right, we're dead.
Oh, my God.
We're alive.
That's crazy.
Actually, the stew is actually the only...
Oh, that's right, Shark.
You're not welcome on this table.
Oh, sack!
We sack!
That's right!
You're not welcome on this table, Shark!
You're not allowed to sit with us.
This chip isn't allowed to sit with me and Sue.
Because you didn't put on the swimsuit skin.
That's on you.
You didn't get the memo.
It's summer still.
It's summer forever.
It's his own fault for not putting on the summer skin.
That's lucky, right?
it's summer forever we can live no we can't she didn't get the memo all right
Wasn't that the mean girl quote?
I haven't watched mean girl in a long, long time.
Not yet.
Jeff is going into my burn book.
Wait, I think I know what they're Spidey.
They're Spidey's like famous or something as well.
They're famous.
Who the fuck are these people?
They're locked in, bro.
If I don't know you, you're not famous.
That's the way.
No, Spidey's top love.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
No, you're not.
You're not because I'm a hero.
I'm still a hero.
Oh my god, please.
Mag, I'm next to you!
What do you mean?
I'm next to you.
I don't understand.
I am ready to put on a show.
It's okay.
Things will be fine.
I'm a little scared.
I hear the spider man.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I don't know who the fuck I killed just now.
Please, please!
There we go.
Wait, okay.
Yay.
We did it.
I would have discovered the accounts.
I got the mutant.
That's all that matters.
Okay, that warm-up over.
I did it.
We play triple support.
Got the mutant.
Dave, I'm not sad anymore.
has been improved.
Day is now optimal.
I got them, unit.
It's just that easy.
Alright, now I can roleplay with the roleplay with the kids.
fellow children.
Would you like to roleplay?
Hello.
Oh, there's a guy here that, hey, you guys want to Hey, girl.
You like what you see?
Hey, you like what you see?
That's right.
Whoa.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, you don't sit down.
That's right.
Don't sit down.
Yeah.
She's here.
She's here for a dinner and a show.
She knows what she was.
That's right, you want to join in, Johnny?
Come on, Johnny, get over here.
Shoot.
Whoa.
She likes what she sees, and she knows.
Oh, man.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let me hear.
Don't worry, girl.
Damn.
Whoa, wait.
Oh, wait.
Bro is watching his sister get a laugh dance.
I just can't do this.
It's just too hard.
What?
I just got here.
Just uninstall.
Alright, we don't want to play.
Are we winning, son?
I won my first game.
I've already.
peaked.
Yeah, dude is already crashing out.
I just got here.
It's already crashing out.
Poor guy.
Hmm.
Yeah, I bought the... I gave in and bought the Mantis.
I bought the Battle Pass for the Mantis skin.
Because, like, it's legitimately...
I own zero Mantis skins.
In the summer Mantis skin is, like, literally the only one that actually, like...
I personally don't like any of the other mantis skins The the summer one was actually the best they've ever done And I was just like, you know what?
I don't know if they'll have another actual decent mantis skin Like, fuck it I don't know, no one's banning, I'm banning Emma Okay, nice, I was gonna say We're like literally full dive here with the Panther and Magic
No, it's only in the Premium Battle Pass It's like $10 What do I play I'll try We're doing ultra and we gotta run Triple support Who's ready for My mag is good I just can't stay the same for my win rate Yo I can play mag if you want No I can play mag It's just like I don't like her I don't like the What is it the dragon one The mantis dragon one I don't know I'm not fan of any of her skins I think the only one that I didn't like I won't say I like it but like I'm okay with okay we're running rocket rocket ultron one or rocket okay we'll have to go Luna I don't know yeah we'll have to go Luna because I have to snowflake the ultron I just don't like I personally just don't like any of the magic skins other than the summer one I think the guys in the galaxy is
one I can build a sand castle yeah I like the guardians okay just cuz like it just reminds me that I like the movie oh wait thank you Jeffy cuz I'm scared oh our Jeff might be already oh no all right we use our bubble already though which is not the best not idea honestly where is our oh my oh my god okay that is not idea okay oh not the most idea moment for us guys it's okay oh they're running triple against triple support we're both running like the fucking worst shit ever the only thing I don't like about like current the current meta is just that triple support is so boring it's so boring I hate it I missed 2 2 2 why are I think triple support is very boring but it's like it's the strongest you know It's like,
what can we do?
It's the strongest cop.
There's like nothing we can really do.
Also, I feel like servers are extra laggy today.
I'm not sure if it's that.
Okay, I don't like how we're just going left.
I live, right?
Save the Jeff!
Oh, we did not save him.
That's very unlucky.
Alright, don't worry.
I decided to use it because I don't trust my team.
I have trust issues.
Hey, can we kill the thing?
Can we kill him too?
Thank you.
See, we're alive.
Jeff, my boy.
Are they still triple tank?
They are.
What the?
They have no DPS players.
They have one actually.
Why don't just go triple support?
You're gonna go triple take.
Hey.
Just go triple support and then make us hate our lives, I guess.
Might as well just go full cancer comp.
Honestly.
Why are you guys going toward our left?
You're going right.
Hello, I'm scared.
Come back and feeding.
Hello, guy.
I don't think he's feeding no more.
That's unlucky.
And we got 96.
That's good.
Alright, we go in.
What's stack?
There's stacking.
Alright.
I'm going in.
I'll go last because I'm the most scared.
I'm the most squishy.
I'm literally just a woman.
There's a shark and a robot that's less squishy than me.
Oh, this guy has all 100%.
You're fine.
I don't know about us, though, but you're definitely fine.
Namor?
Where the fuck is Namor?
He has all, I believe.
Go crazy, dude.
Oh, he's dead.
Wow, they just wiped it every hole.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We can still fight this Please please Mac.
I'm please please I'm Mac please
Mac confused Mac confused What do I just I should have just stopped moving he's a parent you got too disoriented you got too I should have just sorry, I guess I should have stopped moving.
I should have just stood still, I guess.
He just got scared.
That sucks.
I should have just stood still.
Maybe it'd be easier.
That was my bad for thinking I could just shimmy around.
Because I got scared too, you know?
please oh i missed it i knew i was gonna miss it i had a feeling oh wait is that oh wait we're running dual oh that's unlucky dream cat thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you my win rate on mag so bad it's gm3 but top 500 is currently one right now.
Guys, now we know why.
This mag win rate is low.
The poor Tate.
There's no way.
I'm just chilling.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready?
Um, yeah, this guy's using his webcam mic.
There's no way.
He's on a webcam mic right now.
okay um oh man streamer checks aren't hitting walls that's rough buddy that's fucking rough yeah you got his mic from timu that's a five dollar mic
uh i feel like i should go in this now i have to go learn up because He's on Ultron.
He got some budget cuts.
I might have to, like, change my...
What?
We're dead.
We're so dead.
What?
Oh, my God.
Like, I don't know.
There's just so much damage.
Oh my damn it!
Alright, let me...
Um, just...
Let me fix something real quick.
Just throwing it out there.
Oh man, I wanted to make the dot bigger.
It's a little too tiny.
My eyes are too tired.
But...
Okay, now, okay, there you go.
I feel a little healthier now.
I...
I feel...
I feel just a little healthier.
That's nice.
To be fair, No, I can't.
I was gonna say I could go Jeff, but I'd rather be triple support.
I don't think that I...
Yep.
You know...
I... Oh, okay.
Oh, okay.
It doesn't matter.
I lost.
I lost a great god, dude.
Oh my...
It doesn't matter.
The strange just shielded the entire heal.
I should have just fucking killed, like just died.
And we lose two.
I should have just died with it.
No, like the shield can block the heals from the Luna ult.
I should have just died to it.
I wait here until I get the heals.
It's just unlucky.
There is a lot of damage.
There is.
There is so...
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
He's...
They do it.
He was set in the head.
They're running triple take.
You gotta go.
Go Storm!
Holy shit, are they stupid?
Have you guys never played against triple take before?
You go Storm!
That's the easiest Storm game!
Oh my god, Storm is so easy!
I should have just been like, go Storm.
Storm is not even hard.
I play Storm.
Storm's my best DPS.
Literally.
Okay, here's, the NM team goes triple take.
You go Storm.
It's so easy, the farm.
You should have the...
I can't!
I have to play support!
I don't know who any of these people are.
I don't even know who to avoid.
It's just... Oh my god.
No, I know who to avoid.
This guy has zero... I have two final hits.
This guy...
This guy was on... I think this guy was on Ultron.
And he had... He had like...
Two zero final hits.
I have two!
And I was on...
Luna.
Like, he was getting so pocketed.
This guy was getting a pocket of his lifetime.
I don't know.
I just thought.
I thought that they would.
I don't know.
I thought they would have a brain, honestly.
I thought they would, like, everyone knows if any, okay, if the enemy team goes triple tank, you go, you go storm and storm moon.
or Storm Phoenix Moon Knight you go that's the triple DPS because it's so easily farmable or Wolverine it's Storm Moon Knight Wolverine and they pick none of those characters that's crazy there were five characters to pick and they pick none of them
you do here are the five characters you can pick pick if they run triple take storm storm moon night wolverine uh iron man and i get phoenix those are the five characters you could play and and we did zero of those characters
that's actually insane yeah all we had our dps was bucky magic black panther and punishing like we we did just did not care oh my god and i got the freaking i and i got a scarlet main zero to five like they would be like they would be sent back to summer school now who am i gonna banish from this match he was like my entire team would have to be sent back to summer school with how they were playing 10 of us they give a tier 2 sub thank you thank you all right there we go we're running triple take let's just battle all the triple fucking take deniers
bro the thing is this isn't even that low on elo i'm real gm 1 is top 500 i'm like two rank ups away from top 500 oh no i put it down so people can see like who's dying so you can see might you can see like my team disappointing me in real time
okay valid
i just want you guys to know when my team starts disappointing me i want you guys to see it we're running okay triple t the best thing is in viz but I don't want to aim right now after that last game.
Is that it?
We have to run, or Invis, Rocket, or Cloak?
Because Rocket's the best with Triple Tank.
Just because, like, you get so much heals off of it.
Oh, you don't play Cloak.
Rocket, you have to play with...
If you're solo support, you play Rocket.
Because it's the best off...
Oh, well, Jeff is pretty decent, actually.
I could do Jeff.
The thing is, either...
These can do good heals.
We all actually know we're dive.
We're it's fucking Thor.
What am I saying?
Thor's not gonna play with us.
Thor and Angela are not even gonna fucking play with us.
What am I saying?
Jeff only works if we're a brawl comp It only because we're all gonna be bunched up together if I'm playing Jeff, but we're not going to be bunched up together The battle starts in five four three Two One all right, here we go all you need to do is capture the mission area got it the only issue is that our only damage is scarlet witch so like that's that's the only issue which is like not the most idea oh they're running jeff though yeah this is not the best for me only
okay all right nice oh i thought
oh my god oh my god i'm eating i'm eating please please save us it's both your support you have to save us oh my god they got there you go oh wait it's no invis made cloak made it okay we made it we did it we survived that's crazy we survived okay I'm gonna assume all right this is unlucky I'm gonna assume my cloak will out first yes thank God okay thank God I I feel like I am getting...
Oh my god!
I am getting so harassed right now!
Okay, I'm gonna go heal.
I think my cloak will be fine.
Yeah, my cloak's gonna be fine.
I'm gonna let my cloak heal.
Okay, um, heal him.
Alright, I'm good to combo whatever, Angela.
That's it.
That's all I need him to do.
heal him all right oh my god that's unlucky that's five there we go i think we're all in it oh my god yeah we are we are we are we're okay oh my god i'm so scared
i don't know who he ate all right don't worry we're all gonna die regardless as to what happened
oh my god where am i there are so many looks that's crazy nobody is running like we're running triple tank and nobody none of them are running the triple tank counter like what's going on
I'm sorry, Cloak.
It was too late.
I'm sorry.
You were not with me.
It's not my fault.
You were unfortunately just not there.
Okay, I just don't want him to get reset.
He didn't get reset.
That's good.
What is my team doing?
Why did you go in?
Why did our Skylark go right in?
There was no reason.
Oh my god.
Oh, there was nothing I can do.
Alright, at least we swapped.
We swapped off of Triple Tank.
That's fine.
Our Angelus is dead.
There's no...
Oh, wait.
He's not...
Oh, no.
I was gonna say it.
Alright, we have Cloak.
We have our little...
Why are they just...
They're just going in over and over again.
Guys, please, this isn't, I don't know if you think we're in quick play, but it's very, I know it's, sometimes it's very hard to tell we're in quick play or ranked, but like, you see how, um, You see how you guys are trickling in one by one?
Yeah, we're, I know, it's really crazy, but like, yeah.
Are we getting anything?
Oh.
Well, let's hope that...
Nope.
Unlucky.
Oh my god, he's actually won.
He's actually won.
That's so unlucky.
Did we portal?
Please tell me we portal.
We didn't portal.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Oh, this is bad.
I forgot they had a Bucky.
I don't think they know that.
They don't know.
Thank God.
Okay, we did it.
At least I'm trying so hard to save you.
What is this?
Oh!
I tried so hard to save my cloak, but it didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
I had was, my heels were blocked by the strange, so I couldn't do anything.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna go Luna.
We got off triple tank.
Tried so hard and got, I'm avoiding.
the scarlet.
The thing is, I have to snowflake the scarlet too.
That's the worst part.
I'm enabling her.
I am actually enabling her.
Yeah, I was like, oh wait, they have a bucky.
And I'm like, oh thank God.
He didn't see me.
He didn't see me walk forward.
It is not even really the pick here.
But there's nothing else.
Wanda is Not also, not really a pick, but whatever.
I need to change my crosshair too.
My eyes are too tired to look at my current dot.
And I'm too EP to look at that.
The crazy thing is we've done...
Yeah, we should just stop doing the combo.
Like, legitimately, our Thor has more impact, not comboing.
Like...
Every time we've done the combo, Like, we've lost.
So Arthur should just stop.
He should just do it all whenever he the fucking... You're your own man!
You have free will!
Oh, that... Oh, my God.
Alright.
Okay, we're...
Hello.
Goodbye.
That's unlucky.
We are eating.
I need to remember to At this point, he should just combo with the Scarlet And not with our fucking Thor He has more impact as a You're meant to be a solo Okay, nice I didn't ult Because I assumed my cloak would be fine Also, it makes more sense for a cloak to ult that
Okay, that's That's awkward Okay, that's awkward That is very awkward.
Oh, we're dead.
We're so dead.
That's everything.
No, it...
Yeah, no, that seems right.
No, this is actually a team.
I...
Why can't they have the Wanda?
It's not fair.
Why do I?
I'm the streamer.
Where's my privilege?
I swear, I haven't seen a single Wanda all gone up.
Hello?
I thought by being a streamer, I get streamer privileges.
What's the point?
Legitimately, what the fuck is the point?
The streamer, Difa.
Our Wanda doesn't even have... When does she all...
I don't even know when she ulted No, being a tank is worse 100% It's worse because then you can see the people You can see how much you disappoint Alright guys Guys, why are you Okay I like how we all just stood by Why did no one body block That's crazy Oh my god,
Rwanda got a kill That's I didn't realize that was even possible.
That's fine.
In the eyes of the angel.
I swear I've not seen a single alt from where I wanted to.
No, I 100% believe in EOMM.
It's their own version of EOMM.
Like, they don't have the what we think it is, but they made their own version.
There goes my hero.
They know I'm already addicted.
So they can throw anything at me.
They know.
Yeah, all my fault.
Yes.
Yes, it is.
Look at the mirror.
I can't believe you could sarcastically say that too.
I can't believe that.
Yes, definitely my fault.
Yes, it is.
I'm sorry, but yes.
No, you know what?
I'm not sorry.
I'm 100% not sorry.
Alright, I need... I'm too tired to look at my crosshair right now.
I need a bigger...
I need a bigger dot.
I'm too tired.
Where is it?
I don't even know which ones to dot.
Is this one?
With...
Yeah.
It's gotta be bigger.
I'm way too tired to look at this goddamn thing.
It's too tiny.
I'm tired.
Today's my rest day.
Okay, guys.
I was supposed to be resting.
Oh, Mario.
Thank you to Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
At least I have.
At least I have my role play.
Let's see.
What happened to all the Venom enjoyers?
Where did they all go?
Hello, my children.
Would you like some twerking?
Don't worry.
Oh, there's a dance already going on.
Don't worry, guys.
Hello, boys, boys.
Oh, you guys, oh, I'll give you something else to enjoy.
Yeah!
Whoa!
no fun the phoenixes are prude
yeah the phoenixes are prude she a hater she doesn't enjoy real real class she doesn't want dinner in the show
they wanted to keep it a christian servant oh my okay maybe sunday is the worst day real life swear these have been like actual fucking elo terrorist games i all the other days i've been i've been relapsing in rank i've been relapsing in rank i have not had such terrorists this is a weekend it's 100 the fucking weekend guys man bucky they have a bucky player who the fuck oh i guess because he's a magic videos thank you thank you yeah your eyes look so rusty right now nice man way to waste the band oh well i don't fucking know we could do bucky ben second how the oh i'm sorry for not reading their fucking minds that they're gonna ban torch yeah let me open my third party app like what the fuck you blaming me before you think I know what they're thinking I should have I should have known they were gonna bad torch as well I just predict their bends easy are my attacker defense I don't want playing cloak fuck this game sense dokey yeah cuz they could ban three things.
Torch Emma or Phoenix.
How the fuck was I supposed to?
I gambled.
It's one out of three.
That's the go-to bans.
Torch, Phoenix, or Emma?
Why didn't they ban something else?
Why does it have to be me?
I always lose the gambler.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Savvy, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Pretty cheap.
I don't fight to hurt people.
I fight to heal.
Alright.
I don't want to aim right now.
I already aimed last game.
Did my...
Oh yeah, actually, did my crosshair setting go through?
I just want to be sure.
Yeah, I did.
Because it was at 11.
Oh, maybe I should.
What?
I think I might have to go suit.
I don't want to play suit right now.
I want to.
We gotta play close.
If we get grabbed, we get grabbed.
It's just a way of life.
There's so many agile players in this elo though.
It was just meant to be if we get grabbed.
It was meant to be.
Hello.
Don't worry.
Hello, hello, hello.
We gotta play together because we're a team.
We're friends.
All right, there you go.
Hello, there is a...
Hi, there's a Jeff.
There you go.
That's fine.
That Jeff is doing absolutely nothing.
There you go.
There's a Jeff that's doing absolutely nothing.
It's fine.
All right.
Yeah, I was gonna say, why the fuck are you flanking?
Why the fuck did we not kill him?
There's so... And also, Luna, why did you... There's so many questions.
There's no more than any questions.
Okay, the moment I get this, I have to get this first too.
Try my best to get it first.
Oh no.
Oh shit, he's solo alting me bro.
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright, I leave now.
I leave and then we're fine right and then we're fine right We're so healthy How is there how do we have a flanking Jeff at this day and age?
They're not even running triple support.
That's Bro, he's actually not that's actually so bad for them They're not even running triple support.
Okay, we know who we're avoiding I don't think he knows what the new meta is with Jeff god i love like never letting go left click it's actually so fun
yeah now he's blind too whoops oopsie okay i should have healed him that was my bad that was actually my bad all right dark child you might have to please please please please i I know you have all.
I...
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
Like, play with my life more.
Play...
That's fine.
Oh my god, that's okay.
I wasn't, like, scared or anything.
I...
I need it.
Yeah, no, no, that's...
That's okay.
I wasn't, like, scared or anything.
What?
There's a Jeff here.
I have felt that Jeff hit.
She won the GABA.
Thank god.
Alright.
She's so lucky.
Oh, whoa.
Alright.
I believe.
We're 5.
Oh wait, we are 5.
Nice.
We're so healthy.
Where the fuck is the Jeff?
I swear.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Don't worry, Luna.
I got you.
There you go.
There you go, Luna.
Never say I didn't do nothing.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Oh.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Wait.
It worked.
I said with so much confidence.
But I legitimately was worried a little bit.
Just...
I might have...
been worried but I oh okay I don't think that was needed but that's alright that's alright that's alright but is the shark dead I needed this after my Wanda game I fucking needed that actually I deserve this please please I don't deserve this oh my got hey not that though not that oh no wait we don't win that just i just thought we have alts coming back we don't win that instantly punished i had no right click if i had right click we win that unfortunately the right click was non-existent all right What are they doing over there?
Maybe we should help our magic.
I don't know.
It's like...
What?
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Hey guys.
Look at the front.
The Jeff is practically doing nothing.
Like, stand in my little orb of heal.
That Jeff is like basically air.
Alright, trust me.
Jesus Christ.
I'm so...
I'm trying my best to keep her alive, but...
I said my best.
Doesn't mean it's working.
Alright.
Oh my god, please.
There is, like, this guy next to me.
Hello.
Hello!
Give me a sec.
Here we go.
Oh, goodbye.
It was great knowing all...
Oh, God!
He's seen that!
He actually threw!
He forced to see that.
Okay, we know who we're avoiding.
We know who we're definitely avoiding.
Typical chips.
Yeah, He's the... He's the double agent right there.
And your team would not be happy about that.
Skippy, thank you for the doing your biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
I love to kind of keep up with the primetime ideas.
Thanks for being here.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Skippy.
Yeah, that Jeff did not realize...
He's been at, he's been, he apparently had to go to summer school, so he doesn't know the new Jeff meta.
He's like, hey guys, I can't believe my favorite character is finally meta.
I bet his playstyle has not changed whatsoever.
He'd count back from summer school.
He's like, wow, I can't believe it.
My favorite character is finally meta.
Guys, darn, it would be a shame if this playstyle changed.
Really would be.
He's a sleeper agent.
Let's see, no.
Polly, gee.
You forgot to read the patch notes.
Yeah, in the past, to play Jeff efficiently, you gotta play Blanker Jeff.
But now the current meta is literally, like, you just play the team.
That's it.
It's literally just a team.
He's just, like, like, a regular support.
Like, he's actually a support character now.
Okay, I just need to save my...
Right click.
I gotta save my right click for the Spider-Man.
Oh, they got him off.
What the fuck?
He's a Jeff Spider-Man player?
What the fuck is...
What kind of hero pool is that?
He plays Jeff like it's Spider-Man.
That's crazy.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got you.
I mean, that's very...
Oh, I mean, that's alright.
You fucking aim for me.
the moon night we're both there you know yeah that's basically the same character you know yeah they're running they're they're tilted it's literally one no they're 100 tilted but they only have one support so what we're a team that tracks
just wait
no it'll be spider-man that'll get the jeff's jeff skin
he's your friendly neighbor for a reason oh i love that you know what
this was not needed i'm sending a message
It's like it's like I was a squid.
I inked okay.
I got scared I saw my buddy dead and I started inking on
It's my it's my natural response
Here we go Oh shit, that's fine.
Look, I saw my support buddy dead and I was like, what do I do?
Goodbye.
Oh my god, that...
Okay, I was gonna say that Black Panther was 1 HP.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god, our poor Luna.
Yeah, I don't think they're winning this.
they win this like we i deserve to uninstall i think it's time to retire
what if i just my luna will heal me i was like i believe in my luna to heal me time to hang up my mask look he's on the thing now what's going on hey guys what's going on you guys cool there Don't worry.
I believe in my Luna.
Don't worry.
Us against the world.
Guys, do you guys see my thing?
It's over here.
I made up half.
Don't worry.
We just do this.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I should heal.
I should.
Oh, my god.
It's fine.
I should have healed.
I might have trolled a little bit just a little though But like that's how much I believe in my team That's how much I believe That's right I leave now Okay maybe Don't worry we still have Luna We have Luna They have Spider-Man up Don't worry Just keep standing in the bubble the safety heal he has spider-man oh okay there you go oh i have to reload but don't worry i got you i got you i excuse me i okay i deserved it i deserved it i might have like let her die before and that could have been karma
I might have let her die last time.
Yeah, she watched.
She's like, please die.
Please die.
I'm in the game and they're holding us hostage.
How could they do such a thing?
Who would have done?
Who could do that?
Just like League, for real, for real.
the thing is it's not it can't be like one person holding you hostage it has to be two because they because there were too many elot terrorists in the lobby that hold people hostage like actual like hostage situation oh my god how many streamers are there live live on twitch shroud oh wait actually Saikuno I have twitch I have I have,
wait, I have Rust, oh my god, why is it on the super, oh my god, it's too late, it took too long to type.
I was gonna say, Saikuno, I have Rust drops going on right now.
It's too late, the timing's gone.
Everyone's left, I fumbled it.
I fumbled it.
They invited me to the Rust server, but...
I don't feel like rest right now.
I don't want to...
Like, there's just so many people.
Don't.
Both I fumbled.
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
I gotta avoid the Jeff.
I won't be surprised if he was the one that held people hostage.
Wait, was it this guy?
It's my rest day.
I can do whatever the fuck I want.
I'm not...
I'm literally doing overtime right now.
I'm on overtime.
overtime
I just want to play it rival see no one has yelled me at me you guys I swear to God I swear the moment I go live Everyone's a fucking pussy Because they don't they don't want to be exposed on stream
Everyone's a fucking pussy now how about How am I gonna farm these children for content?
You don't want to be seen being like little bitches and passive aggressive fucks.
Crazy.
How would I farm these kids?
Alright.
I'm so sad.
I'm like the last remaining Venom player.
happened to our fall of venom players where did they all go where did all my road players go what what society is this we truly live in a society the last remaining venom twerker
guys what happened come on you don't want to you don't want to hit me guys come on come on come on that's right oh that's my body guide yeah oh my god no don't sue why you body she body blocked not she body blocked the door i couldn't leave i couldn't leave That's so hot.
Jeez.
Holy shit, how bad are you for body blocking that entire door?
The body block is crazy.
Who am I gonna vanish from this match?
Torch.
That was a fucking crazy body block.
Those hips are lethal.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, you bought all the pay.
Oh, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Yes.
I'm at Parallel Collab out right now.
I just want to check it out.
There's three days left for the pre-order.
It's the exclamation point collab and check it out.
I'm adding Emma.
Just because we don't have an Emma player, apparently.
No Emma player.
What can we do?
Oh, yeah, it's September right now.
If you'd like to subscribe, it's currently...
Is it 30% off or some shit?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
This month or like until October for...
Yeah, this month only.
All subscriptions are 30%...
Oh, 25%.
Sorry, I can't read.
Are 25% off.
Like the moon.
I shine in darkness.
So it's cheaper.
Cheaper subs.
How often are you going?
Okay, but like...
What about the emojis, though?
Okay, but all...
But like...
But we don't think about how often I'm going to stream.
Think about the emotes.
Like, look at all these wonderful emotes you can have and use on other streams.
On other people's streams.
Come on.
We need to make people happy.
Heroes make them safe.
Maybe I can do both.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
She's cooking.
Pamela, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
And if you have Prime, Amazon Prime you can subscribe to your favorite stream or oh no you can subscribe to only me for free and so I have a special deal with Amazon right now where if you have uh Twitch I have Amazon Prime you get to subscribe to me for free mm-hmm chip thank you for the Twitch Prime thank you thank you hey thank you for this Twitch Prime thank you thank you see it's working only on my channel do I have this deal I have this very special deal I put on fucking Groot because like,
oh my, they're running ultra on triple T, a triple support.
I am Groot.
Wait, do they also have Groot?
Oh my god, they also have Groot.
I am Groot.
I'm just gonna put on the Groot.
I like the cold.
Oh my god, he already has all...
That's crazy.
I don't think none of us are close to all right now.
Wait, unless...
Yes!
Oh, goodbye, everybody.
It's just you and me, I guess.
Okay.
Um...
I stalled it as long as I could.
And then they manned themselves it.
Hello!
I'm scared.
Oh, I forgot that you see.
What was that res?
I...
What the fuck was that res?
Wait.
I was just in there.
Oh, our mantis should have saved her up for the res.
I just came in and it was just death.
I was not expecting that res.
That was, I felt like a baby sea turtle hatching up from the ground and then there's, they were all the seagulls ready to fucking eat me.
Oh god, like right into hell.
Like I was the sea turtle that was not gonna make it.
I poked my head outside and it was just over.
I didn't remember to use my atom.
Oh, I'd rather have an ultra than an atom.
Honestly.
Extermination!
Oh!
Alright, we should go up now.
Or even like a Jeff, honestly, because we're a brawl comp.
We're a fucking full-on brawl comp.
So like a Jeff would make sense.
Because you can build alt faster.
What is it I have my snowflake on?
Oh, the Groot.
Okay.
No, it has to be on the Groot.
I am Groot Watch They're gonna get eaten The moment I hit that alt button They're gonna get eaten I am Groot I am Groot
Should I calm?
I'm calming Wait, I'll first Oh, never mind Yeah, fuck it JK
JK Oh my Do we have Adam res I assume we can res And then I can all Right?
We're gonna do that gamer move right there And then And then I do this That's right And then And then we're all okay
Oh okay I did realize they would fucking kite back that's crazy that's a really good kite honestly that was such a good kite that was my bad i didn't think they were that smart i was like i'm in there was no i was like there's no way i'm in such a i'm not like that have a elo for them to fucking kite back reportedly all right i'm fucking going back I am Groot.
Where's the...
Where are they?
Wait, where are they?
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
Oh, our matches didn't have all...
Ready?
Can we touch?
I don't know.
We could technically touch with...
No, we can't touch.
We actually cannot touch.
Nope.
Nope, I don't believe.
Oh!
That's unlucky.
Alright, well, it looks like the Mantis ult's first, so I don't want to risk it.
Because I was like, I'll first and then Mantis went, friends!
And I was like, okay.
Okay, I wait.
That's just unlucky.
Alright, I want to ult for my...
There you go.
Friends!
This is the only way I can feel safe.
Hold the man.
I know.
We're here to put on a show.
And then this is where we...
We have a res, right?
Our Adam died.
It's still possible!
Rise, my friends!
See?
I knew it.
I don't know we can push all the way that's the that's the only do I trust my team let's find out Jesus Christ this mantis does not care when's it's like I'm playing silk song right now I don't think I can build my own time rivals has spoiled me so much with support though like I actually feel doing something.
I swear to God, any other, if I play like Overwatch or anything, wins!
It's a big old fat, super fat.
The way I froze him too!
Man!
Keep staggering.
The question is, can we push all the way?
That's the question right now.
I have a...
I feel like we're so up close, but that's okay.
I like to play with a little fear.
I like that little fear.
You know?
It makes it so much more exciting.
We're down!
I'm dead.
I'm so dead in there.
Oh my god!
Oh, our item was...
Adam, why would you ever, like, be playing with us when you have us?
Let me get back.
Oh, no.
Our Adam can't even up.
Adam, you're fucking crazy.
I can't even...
I don't know why our Adam played up front with Rez.
Like, the moment you have Rez, you hide i i mean mantis team up is it really that worth maybe the luna would be better
why yeah adam i can't even i don't even think if i use my luna team up it would have done anything i would have lived but my entire team would have died i'm luna snow like the matter they play ultra um i'm just like even i'm win-loss win-loss lost but i'm also like solo cute apparently like i was told that every like top 500 player is just three stacking because you can three stack till celestial
really luna mantis please i want a real support the winter soldier it's an honor you're one of the best so i'm just hey i'm just like through it hey so funny thing i only play mantis well funny thing i have an avoid slot
that's so funny i also have an avoid slot
isn't that funny yo bro just go dps then
i think that sucks like nobody fucking hits the thing
This is- I have not seen Loki in so long, I swear.
I feel like Loki is only viable in...
Um...
Please, you are all walled off, please.
I am trying my best to- My DPS, unfortunately.
Although they did buff me, it's still not as strong as I would like it.
A little healing to take care of.
Go to the back room.
Alright, I reload.
all right let's hope our mag lives there you go i have a portal i got portal nice
yeah back to triple support technically you don't have to stand on the cart yet because it's odd you'll see that it's auto you can push up a little bit holy holy you're so lucky acknowledged
I'm just gonna make sure.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Three, two, one.
Counting out for myself.
Damn.
Do we have follow-up?
Wait, we don't even have Maga.
Oh my god, we don't even have Maga.
Oh my.
That's very unfortunate.
What?
Did he got Shia?
Did he get shield?
I don't think you're a deep yes, bro.
I don't think you're a healer.
I just think you're pure dog shit.
I think that's probably what the problem is, bro.
Yeah, absolutely fucking silent or shit.
I mean, you're just a fucking...
You see, if I wasn't streaming, he would have said that to me.
You see?
If he wasn't streaming, he would have said that to me.
Unfortunate.
I like...
Are you serious?
Oh, nice.
We're going to have to kill him too.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
I don't have vault for Punisher now.
I do.
Don't worry.
As long as we don't stand in front of a Punisher, we can live.
There's a lot to ask.
our team but like what yeah me too oh my god okay i oh my mag oh oh my god okay okay somehow oh my god okay somehow i saw like so many things that could happen but didn't it was crazy so many things could happen that did not Jesus somehow some oh we still lose this yeah somehow we actually still lose this I I don't know I don't know how this is possible you're 12 and 13 dude like please bro please a triple heal ultron go go tank I don't know do something bro you're so fucking bad I'm not bubbling you here I witnessed a hate crime Actual pure hate crime right there He's so real for that He's actually so real It's
This is the content I want I hope that puncher is having a good time.
The thing is, we could literally go...
Not Loki.
We have to play Loki.
I forgot we have a group.
Loki is so bad now.
I know!
This is the Marvel Revival experience you came for.
Is it not, guys?
Hello.
I'm reloading.
I'm sorry.
It was very hard to see.
There was a lot of stuff going on.
Where am I?
It's just all.
Oh my god, he got a kill.
Go second morning.
Go.
Oh my god, he's doing it!
Now they have strange alt.
Ready, guys?
Get ready!
Did you see that?
Wow.
It's like...
It's like I could predict our future.
How did you know, Doki?
Are you hacking?
I don't know.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
That's very unfortunate.
Um, hey.
Hello.
You think the group's still there?
Oh my god, please get away from me.
Which?
Did you break your curse?
Who if I punch the portal upstairs?
What if I just punch the portal upstairs?
What the fuck?
All right, let's see.
They used to be an Iron Fist main, and then Iron Fist got gutted, so...
So now they play whatever they want.
This straight vegetable.
Oh my god, I ate bad pizza, and now eating pizza wants to play.
All right, let's avoid him.
All right, let's look.
all right you can't you sort of did okay i'm willing to risk it all right let's see oops i accidentally closed my my thing he sort of broke this curse it's sort of broken
uh i'm so sad what happened we're like a dying race now what happened The land used to be filled with venom twerkers.
Why did they all go extinct?
It's so sad.
It's so...
Hello.
Hello, lads.
You ready for some action?
I hear someone's special day.
He's like, no.
No.
He paid for double the entertainment.
Bum bum.
Yeah.
See?
Oh shit, Peter!
Let's go!
Let's go, Peter!
Is that the turkey?
You know it!
Smack that!
Oh my god, wait, we gotta dance with the girls.
Give me a sec.
I didn't realize there was a girl party up there.
Don't worry, ladies.
Did someone ask?
Where?
For the special...
The special...
Entertainment?
Right here.
That's... No!
They're like, stop.
Ladies only.
Hey, hey, technically I could be a lady too.
You think about it.
Venom has...
Venom doesn't... We don't know what Venom's actual gender is.
Guys.
I could be a lady too.
There is female Venom!
Yeah!
I could be female Venom!
I'm just...
You're right, I'm just showing the superior cake.
Exactly.
My cake is just better.
Yeah, see?
Venom's...
Venom symbiotic bio is technically with Mary Jane right now.
So I'm positive the ladies.
Yeah, Venom is where the hook...
It could be Mary Jane in that body right now.
You don't know that.
He doesn't take off that mask.
That could be... Mary Jane just could be like extra jacked up.
You don't know that.
True.
He could be extra jacked up right now.
You know, she went into bodybuilding class.
No.
She could have been into bodybuilding.
Don't shame her.
You don't know that.
She could be doing bodybuilding.
Why are you shaming Mary Jane?
That's crazy that you would shame her.
That's messed up.
Mary Jane does not deserve that.
It's because Spider-Man doesn't know that it was actually Mary Jane.
Mary Jane's, like, pretending to be Eddie.
You don't know.
Alright.
Torch time.
Oh, man.
I just realized I ran up water.
Hmm.
This is my last bottle of water.
That's right.
We've never heard Eddie talk at all.
It could be Mary Jane.
You'll need a talk I will be Jeff.
Yeah, but that's just that one skin.
All the other skin is Mary Jane.
It's just gender swap.
The Phoenix skin?
It's just that one skin that Eddie's in.
Everything else is Mary Jane.
I don't believe you.
That's on you.
talk to chat today.
It's okay, we got this.
That is lore accurate.
I know nothing about Marvel, but I think she's right.
Were you hungry when you came up with your name, Tenkow Chicken?
Oh, I was gonna say eating pizza?
You mean?
Four, three, two, one.
Oh my god, girl?
No, that's Mary Jane.
Oh, that's fine.
Angela can deal with it.
If Angela loses, that's on her.
But what the fuck?
Oh, I ain't dealing with that.
There you go.
We just slowly just pushed the card away.
Oh, shit.
Look at that.
Yeah, that's a little stupid.
Yeah, fucking stupid.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck was over there?
Don't worry, I'm slowly...
Wait, is that?
Oh, no, it's town.
I was gonna say, am I...
Oh, wait.
They're playing triple support.
We're playing triple support.
Look at that.
What a great game.
Oh, they can't portal.
I love this.
I love Marvel Rivals.
Look at that.
This is a heal support society.
And we live in it.
Left click!
Woo woo woo woo woo woo woo woo woo woo!
Whoa!
I missed.
I can't miss that!
Oh shit!
Is this Charler back here?
Oopsie.
I was maybe being a little too silly.
Sorry, I was being a little too silly.
there Jeff no sorry I used up my silly meter for that report Jeff all right that's okay I'm gonna destroy your platform I'm gonna destroy my own team's platform just cuz I can't what am I doing that.
And then...
Oops.
Hello.
Yay!
They're like...
Okay, I hope that they don't lose this because I'm literally...
I literally sent them all behind us.
I was like, they're all...
My kill!
That's right, after that.
I'm killing stealing that's right my kill okay I am I am might be a little too silly no we didn't we won and kill stealing and didn't even kill them we got the point guys it's not just about kills guys it's all about what we had we got we got the objective,
didn't we?
Did we... Oh, they double all of this.
That's a little sad.
Oh.
Look, I tried my best.
Like, literally, what else can I do?
I spit on you.
That's, like, my only ability.
What can I do?
Look at that.
Yeah, the... No, no.
We were playing Objective.
I was being a team player.
Look at me, girl.
The most team player you can see.
Look at that.
Alright, I hope our Luna has up.
Oh, she...
Wait, she does.
If she dies, you have all!
What?
Oh my god, that's unlucky.
I timed it wrong.
Okay, I have to go sue.
And they're playing.
I thought...
No, I thought the punishable was over.
I was going to be like, yoink.
I timed it wrong.
Math is...
Guys, do you guys know I almost failed math?
I counted in my head, but it was not the right type of counting.
That's crazy, right?
account I believe that there you go we should kill that master let me just say there's no way so now there you go you're welcome look at that I played a real character there you go it's like I know how to play invisible women or some shit is that crazy like i know how to play this character holy fuck
it's crazy
yeah the move was calculated it was in my head but like it was the wrong kind of counting i'm not the type who fades quietly into the background okay but what if
thoughts thoughts and prayers
holy shit i hope you make it
what pray pray
Thank you for the tier one, so I'm thinking, thank you.
Violet, uh, Violet, thank you for the raid.
I got a great stream.
He called me an ape.
What is this?
Okay, chill out, Colson.
He's just awful at the game, and we don't have to go that far.
Okay, never mind.
He called me an ape.
What is this?
Look, he's sick, okay.
Okay.
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, two, two, one.
Nancy.
I was like, bro, chill out.
Stop being so toxic.
Never mind.
He called me an eight.
That's crazy.
That's fucking funny, though.
Never mind.
You can cook his ass.
Jesus, I have to back up fully.
Holy fuck, calm down, everybody.
Calm down.
That is so much damage.
Oh, where am I?
It's so empty.
There you go.
Okay, that's on you.
I don't know what the fuck why you were standing there.
I don't know why.
I don't know why Luna stood there.
That's on you.
We're just chilling.
Look, I might have been silly, but I wasn't not, I was, I was never mispositioned silly, okay?
I was everything else but mispositioned.
And that Luna is crazy for standing that.
Look, I die before- I don't die, I just use the alt rod.
There you go.
See?
How?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Don't worry, we're fine.
I said I'm fine.
Sorry.
Let me be- I'm fine.
See, we are fine.
Just not her.
I don't know where the mag was trying to fucking shoot, though.
I was curious about that.
I'm gonna push him away.
Jesus, we gotta touch.
Can we touch?
Oh, that's unlucky.
That's unlucky.
I hope our Luna lives.
Nope, 92.
Fire!
Thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
That's fine.
See, guys, I'm doing my job.
I could go at him.
How much do I want to make this harder for my team?
That's the question.
Alright.
Well, I want to make this harder.
Holy shit.
That's fine.
We just got...
There you go.
I did double fall!
pull come on how is he still okay he's still alive that's cool it's like double pull doesn't matter no more that's fine hey nice yay there is oh my god when she does purple it makes me so scared honestly i i'm so scared
I Hope that we backed up Did we back up?
Like, where's my tanks?
What?
Where did they go?
I heard back up and then they disappeared They backed so far up I was like Where did they go?
At least I didn't have to waste this Well, goodbye
That's very unlucky That's okay.
They can't get us.
We're in our safety bubble.
We're so safe.
We're no longer safe the moment the bubble is gone.
Please.
Please let me still be in my safety bubble.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
He has...
You belong to me soon.
She has her mind control shit.
Okay.
There you go, see?
I love triple support.
Yay!
What the fuck?
Like, is he playing Attack on Titan?
He does Attack on Titan name.
I was like, where did he come from?
Luna, you are, you're giving me like, stress.
And I don't deserve that.
I already have enough of that and everything else.
I do.
Oh.
Let's hope she doesn't get my own control.
There we go.
Look at that.
I protected her.
I'm a hero.
There we go.
Oh my god, Angela.
I actually need that all charge though.
Look at this.
What an easy game.
Bravo is so cruel.
It gives me an easy game than a hard game.
And an easy game and a hard game.
game.
I'm not allowed to chill.
Why can't I have, why can't the, why can't the streamer privilege where everybody just keeps throwing non-stop every, every game?
But like on their team, not on my team, though.
There you go.
Yes, we can.
All right, one again.
I know.
Hello, there is there is hair.
Hello.
Why are you in his face?
That's a Punisher.
Oh my god, you're crazy.
Wait You had off Why are you still ego killing him?
Why are you egoing him?
That look I've never been that silly I I've never look I've never been been that oh my god art she she actually was was being so silly that's crazy
look i was silly but i was never that silly that's the thing i've never been that silly she actually lost the satra the ego
Look, I was never that silly.
I stopped being silly.
I never went that silly.
Never go full silly.
She went full silly.
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, I thought he was aiming for me and the Luna.
Okay, I don't have anything for that.
Okay, that's fine.
I have it here.
We can use to engage with that.
There you go, fight this.
Use this.
That's right.
Yoink.
That's right!
Okay, that's also right.
Yeah!
Okay, maybe not that.
Maybe that's too much, guys.
Too much, too much.
We were too silly.
Guys, guys.
Too much, too much silly.
Too much.
We could have saved the Angelo.
Okay, I'm just gonna use this and save her.
Nice.
Dial it back a little.
and chill, chill a little bit.
I hate Celestial players.
Chill, I'm actually platinum.
Bro, I wish I was in a Celestial lobby.
Those lobbies seem fun.
Yay!
Alright.
I don't even know who they were shit talking.
Who was the thing?
Oh, this guy.
I mean, he wasn't that bad.
Maybe he was just on drugs.
I don't think he was that bad.
The fact that I'm surprised I had the most heals, honestly.
I was playing Jeff.
I was playing Jeff in the first half.
So I'm surprised.
I was...
I don't really look at it.
Alright.
I gotta go pee up your back.
Wait, don't worry.
I'll give you a dinner and a show.
I'll be back.
Came back just in time.
Oh, I don't have water, but I have lemonade.
So I'll just...
I'll just drink lemonade.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
The cake is the dinner.
You get dinner and dessert.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Isn't that great?
You got a double special.
Who am I going to be in this economy too?
A cake and dinner.
You get cake for dessert and dinner.
Oh my god.
You should be like honored.
It's cost safe.
Exactly.
We're saving money.
I
don't know.
Why are we banning all of the time?
I'm not Emma.
I'm banning Emma.
Oh, I fucking feel it, Emma.
I don't want that mind control on me.
That Snow Bunny mind control.
Get that away.
Be gone, witch!
Be gone!
My mind is strong as steel.
You ain't mind controlling me.
Shut up.
I'd let her wake!
You're weak.
Burn the witch.
Weak willed.
Do you know even know what that means?
Cosmic rays didn't let me who I am today.
My family did.
Let's go.
I'm good playing.
I think like this season has been the least I played Luna ever.
I don't know.
I just want more variety now in my life.
I'm sorry, Luna.
I'm just...
I don't know.
She's just...
It's so boring.
It's just so boring.
They changed the ceiling?
The ceiling or the other ceiling?
Yeah, ever since I found out she's immune and I felt so betrayed.
No exception.
Wait, hey guys.
Hey guys.
Hey guy!
Oh, it's all right.
We don't need him, I guess.
What is that portal?
I am scared.
I have to go on the other side.
I was so confused.
I was actually so confused.
Okay.
I did not know where to look at.
Okay, I don't have another push, so that could not...
I push him away!
There's the supports over that side.
Like, maybe we could kill the supports on the right.
That's a silly concept, right?
Do we...
Hey guys, how about we kill the supports on the right side that are by themselves?
Yeah, I'm done with you.
I'm done with you, Luna.
I'm done playing with you.
I mean after like what four seasons of Luna I just feel like Because I felt like this season There is Okay I was so burnt out of Luna Because like What the fuck Oh shit Because this season was literally just It was Luna Loki all the time It was just Luna Loki Luna Loki And I was so tired I was so tired of that So like But this season,
every support, like, is viable now.
Like, last season, it was literally Luna Loki, Luna Loki, Luna Loki.
But this season, you can play any support.
You can play Jeff, you can play Invis, you can play Cloak.
Like, it's not Luna Loki anymore.
So I'm just, like, I'm just taking advantage of that.
That can actually play other things.
I'm like, oh my god, I can play other characters now.
like I'm not locked in please tell me oh thank God it's gonna it's like this guy
ah oh holy shit where did I go okay I need to know where did I go I got
so scared Guys, I'm trying to heal you.
I really am.
Please.
I'm doing my best to give you all the heals possible Holy shit There you go Oh my god, I have my heal support.
Am I all now?
I'm a hero I am ready to put on a show I'm a hero There you go okay that's fine i blocked it holy shit i'm gaming i'm a hero i'm actually a hero no way you owe me your life i better be in your will your children your i better get your first barn After that,
I- Some heroes wear swimsuit.
I demand her firstborn For what I did.
It feels good to step outside my bubble every now and then.
That was gaming that I actually saved her life
I think her firstborn and be in her will when she dies Is with how she was playing?
Yeah, that's what she gonna do with him That's not important the important is I get it Not if when I get it.
Yeah
All right See this is why I'm top five and I was top I'm watching out.
This is why I'm watching out this is why I'm I was top 500 when the game had a bigger player base.
This is a waste of my jump, but like, I don't really care.
I like how we could have helped, but nah, fuck that, I guess.
Okay, I healed, I healed, I healed.
You can't blame me.
I healed.
Please, okay.
Oh my god, I'm scared.
I don't like it here.
I'm sensing.
I know that...
Alright, there is a venom on the Luna and me and like, please.
We can't cap.
Oh, I missed the pull.
He was so fast.
He was zooming.
That man zoomed.
Your Honor.
Where?
I need...
Oh.
That's fine.
That's not as fine.
He was a little bit too...
Oh my god, that's good.
That's huge.
That's too much.
That's a little too much.
But that's okay.
Nice.
I have a lot now.
all me yeah all me wait i'm not i'm not my legs are too weak i need to put some me on my boat my legs i couldn't reach it watch this okay never mind i thought guys i told you guys i'm not good at counting i thought he was gonna swing look i thought he was gonna swing okay it looks swing up it looks like he was swinging i know he's alting he wants to all he wants the all i'm not looking at him wait where did he go where did the thing go i am strengthened for battle where did he go he disappeared of course your grippers are out it's fucking summer vacation there you go look at that oh it's fine he's still okay that's the That's fine.
So he was very low and I got scared for him.
There we go.
See?
We did it.
All right, I forgot about her.
Okay, I met up nice.
I know he wants to do it.
I knew it.
Please, I saved your life.
All right.
I leave.
I don't know what's going on inside there, but I believe in my team.
Don't worry, just play behind my shield!
See?
Easy.
Look at that.
No, it's eternal.
Summer vacation will never end!
No!
Don't say that!
It's summer forever!
I don't want to go back.
It'll never end.
Yay!
Now that I've won two games in a row, as per EOMM law, I shall lose 10 now.
Yeah, it's still hot outside.
There's nothing...
It's not like it's global warming or anything, but it's still hot.
So it means summer vacation forever.
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm working on the Pantheon and Hotly Night right now.
Got three or five endings.
Oh, shit.
Good luck.
Good luck with the rest of the Pantheon.
Oh, Amalee, thank you for the raid.
I heard you were playing Rivals as well.
Thank you for the raid.
I hope you had a great stream.
From Rivals to more Rivals.
I hope you were able to rank up.
I'm just been messing about.
They rank.
Amalee's learning the recorder.
She's learning to record her.
Next, see.
Thank you for the five gift that sells.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm just, I'm also making you, dragging you back into a rival's basement.
That's right.
You get more rivals.
For those who don't know me, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but today I am on Twitch because I had a craving for a rank today.
And I was like, And I had like a team that yelled at me last game off because I was playing rank off stream And I was like, you know what if I'm gonna get yelled at on if I'm gonna get yelled at and rank I might as well monetize it and So then I was like fuck it.
We're streaming and then coincidentally I started streaming and all these Pussies stopped yelling at me because they don't want to get exposed It was just like well dokey bit.
I love your stream.
Oh, yeah, oh
Fucking cowards I wouldn't never Anyway Anyway so We're playing Rivals But yes check me out on YouTube I'm usually there Today is just a gorilla day Because I was like If I'm gonna get yelled at Playing Rivals on my off time Fucking streaming it
uh but yeah i used to be for those who don't know i used to be top 500 in rivals but that was like in the beginning of season one zero season zero and zero season one now i just play whatever i'm just chilling now i play uh i used to be a luna main but like i got bored of luna Because last season it was literally Luna Loki.
Like in season 2?
I don't remember.
I actually don't remember.
I'm gonna play.
Is this Brawlcom?
Technically it's Brawlcom so I can maybe get away with Jeff.
I don't know.
Or maybe...
The thing is, we're on Groot.
Groot is so hard to heal.
Uh...
Let's see.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just know I have, I think I only have two top 500 badges.
I might try for top 500 this season because it's a dragon.
That badge is a dragon and it's really cute.
I like it.
I mean, I could try.
I'm really bad as a result.
No, maybe I shouldn't.
Now, now when I just got raided, I'll play Invis.
Invis does more heals.
Oh my god, all the team up is just like, what are we doing?
I should actually try a little I should not throw I just got raided maybe I shouldn't throw me oh yeah no I should there you go I got you I got you girl I know how to peel oh my god this is full dive this is full dive this is oh dive this is not gonna be fun for us all right Luna we're fun.
But I believe.
I believe.
Okay, he's dead.
He is absolutely dead.
Don't worry.
There you go.
There we go.
Come on, he's won.
It's a little scary.
It's full dive.
They're running full dive.
It's a little scary.
But Luna and I, we got this.
We just got it.
protect each other if we play together as a family we'll be fine we all stick together you and I Luna oh my god Luna what did I say what did I say Luna oh my Luna, we had one instruction.
Oh my god, thank god, okay.
Thank god, okay, thank god.
I messed up his thing.
No.
Classic.
I was like, don't worry, Luna.
We sick to get there and we can live.
She dies.
Oh, no.
unfortunate our one plan fails it's crazy all right that's good i don't have to use my ult yet nope oh that's fine that's fine i don't have to use anything oh my god oh my god oh my god
my jump he actually oh my god he was playing fast smash bros he downwards smashed my jump that's
crazy bro edgy kept you no way bro that's crazy wait our venom oh i was gonna say he was still alive i could have altered that i didn't realize he was gonna live there you go we should kill him
I swear to god I swear to god I swear oh my god I lived through so much
I oh my god I lives through hell I just didn't die I live through hell there wait we're still fighting now you guys are fucking crazy that's a waste of it oh they have three we lose the fight you know yeah that was unfortunate He literally he won that because the spider-man else if the spider-man didn't oh we win I'm so scared.
I'm so scared That's fine.
It's technically not fine, but like I'm scared
Okay I anything about it i lived i almost lived through three alts i oh i didn't even hear the dark child honestly oh i mean i could technically pull them back i'm gonna live here i saw the spy man i got scared okay we have like two fights though this sucks because they're running full dive that's scary i hear the spider man i hear him nice i swear to I was gonna say,
I literally pulled him.
What?
Oh, and that's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
It's okay.
That's okay.
That's fine.
That's...
Oh!
Yes!
Oh my god.
We win this.
That's right.
predicted and fucking predicted get out of here get your ass out of here i'll push at your own kobe play get out this is my domain
shouldn't have floated so high family still comes first that's right the almighty push
We got this.
I don't know we actually got this, but we got this.
That actually clutched us because I think that the strange was fully charged.
I'm pretty sure.
Move out of the way.
Nice.
Oh, we're back on Groot.
Why?
Oh, I guess there's no...
No, environmental, I think?
Yeah.
You can't do environmental here.
Makes sense.
Yay, Bob the Builder.
I was gonna say, why did he...
Let me break this with my...
Look at that.
I can't even break this.
That's how little my DPS is.
That's so sad.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's...
Nice.
Nice hit.
I'm scared.
Oh man, we're alive.
We're alive.
That's right, get back to your spot, man.
You think we're done with you?
Get over here.
Oh, I got e-lifts.
He lives.
I pulled him back, but I couldn't.
Yeah, he ran like a bitch.
That's right.
Oh, I hear the Angela.
I gotta get ready.
Oh, that's fine.
He's fine.
See, he's fine.
I want to save my...
I want to save...
There you go.
I had a feeling, yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What did the spider-man get?
I was trying to peel!
Where did he come from?
I mean, I'll take it.
Oh shit!
I was just trying to peel.
Push!
Oh my god.
I can't push all that.
I can't push all of that.
Oh my god.
It's...
It's everything I put.
It hit everything.
There was nothing I...
That was actually nothing I could do.
That was pure hell.
That was just straight up...
Straight up cyber bullying.
Yeah, I lived a lot longer.
than I expected but what I had to go through there
don't worry don't worry stop please I always care for you but why would you why you died you died I always cared for you I don't understand Duna I'm always there for you why would you why are you never there for me oh my god I'm always here for you why could you never be there for me why are you a damage why are That's it.
I'm going.
Oh, I won.
Who are you, bro?
Holy shit.
Good odds, too.
The godless.
Yay!
I won on Jeff!
Another epic victory!
Yay!
Both of us in PN.
Thank you for the 100 pitties.
Yay!
It's a Jeff win.
Yeah, good Jeff game.
Thank you.
It was my best Jeff game.
See, the Ludo was there for you.
Yay.
I swear.
Our Ludo, I don't, our Ludo was on, was on DPS, was on damage boost for like 80% of that all.
That was crazy.
like excuse me ma'am excuse ma'am excuse me we all got angela altered why is the ring purple why is the why is my ring purple in this angela oh it's a little weird isn't it ma'am just a little quirky
yay purple means heal right i didn't realize the i didn't realize the change They changed it in the patch notes.
Why I get ad for adult diapers?
Because the ads are made for you.
You do know that, right?
The ads are personalized.
And why did you out yourself?
Oh my god, there's a fellow.
There's a fellow, Vedam.
It's charting self-reported.
You didn't know.
not need to self-report, bro.
Hello, everyone.
Where is my fellow?
Vendom.
Hey, there.
Wait, actually.
Oh, hey.
Hey, there, Mr. Fantastic.
I heard.
I heard Sue has been out of town.
Mr. Fantastic.
Hey.
Come over here.
That's right.
Yeah.
You're getting lonely, aren't you?
stop that's a very bad it's an open marriage we all know it why else would name were if he's slapping that that's right don't worry he's not open home record
Look, he's even, you know what the worst part is?
The worst part is that he's in his wedding outfit right now.
That's the worst part.
He's in his groom outfit.
That's on him.
You mean the best part?
What, Chiru, do you think you want to be today?
You're right.
Hey, did anyone hire?
We didn't hire Venom for the bachelor party.
Oh my god, everyone's.
too happy everyone's too happy guys calm down we're playing rivals calm down everyone this is marvel rivals i might honestly run penny for first point and then also up to angela for later what do you like with penny like strange oh wait literally just play what your heart desires If I play a rocket,
is it time?
My heart desires you.
I'm not gonna lie, Penny works with pretty much anything.
That's hot.
You can say you're the best, yeah?
No, no, no, no.
I'm going to tell you the best in America.
North Africa.
I bet you'd be the best player in, like, South Sudan.
Why do we not like the South Sudan come from?
a little bromance in rank doesn't hurt nobody oh just a little bromance in rank guys it's time by the way number two you don't have to play rock if you don't want i don't need the team up i don't care i'm so low support not glitched yeah the the little feature that the game has feature that's right obviously time i i can after the last game i'm relaxing guys I tried last game right now.
I'm relaxing.
I'm relaxing now.
I tried already I already try hard now it's chill time.
Love can bloom even in Marvel Rivals.
If you want to you can swap now otherwise you can save.
You want something.
We're solo sup rocket.
Rocket rocket is best solo support.
It's true.
It's actually true.
When you run solo support, you have to play Raqqa.
It's unfortunately sad, but it's true.
I get my break time.
I'm not going to go for a pool.
This is my little break time.
My relax time.
Wait, I hear more than one.
I know.
I'm going to need help with this.
fighter dies where is our Luna oh there he is don't worry rocket is very bad at peeling so don't worry rocket is one of the worst characters to peel but don't worry don't worry oh my god please please just it's okay we're a fight it's actually We're still.
Hey, Ryan.
Good pull.
Yay.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Hello.
There is a rocket.
Oh.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Does he?
Yeah, okay.
Yes, there is.
That's the monkey guy.
That's the rocket guy that I play with.
That's the rocket guy.
There's a rocket guy.
That's what he's doing instead of healing you.
Don't die, man.
Luna I got you I got you I'm right-clicking that's all I could do oh my God that's all I could do rock please oh that's unfortunate that's unfortunate none of us took damage none of us took any damage I'm sorry it's crazy no one took any damage that entire round Wait.
Can we?
Nope.
Why did no one stand in front of...
Oh my gosh, I stood in front of him.
I thought, like, I as the rocket would not be the body blocker, you know?
I thought out of everybody, I'd be the last person to be body blocking.
It is crazy that that became my job.
That should go.
You got Hulk in your belt?
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you.
Let's go.
They're going to destroy it.
Oh, they're not shooting it.
Thank God.
Okay, they're stupid.
Let's go.
I stopped.
Oh, nice.
Oh, you're seeing me.
I stopped it.
All right, nice.
Okay, I have to swap off.
Oh, it's fighting coming in for an off.
He is?
Goodbye.
You got this.
See, look.
I told you.
I told you he's got this.
Bro, this rocket's the scariest player in the game.
What?
Is that Smokey Amour?
This is my...
How is he scary?
He's a raccoon.
How?
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
We're peeling.
we're peeling we're peeling we're still peeling oh okay that's fine it's fine it's like right there it's fine okay i'm gonna put that knot there oh my god please please please please please please please please please please i'm a little concerned that okay i'll put it here he doesn't know okay he doesn't know he doesn't know that the thing is right there All right,
that's unfortunate Thanks you guys are down your Luda.
Yeah There you go
It's fine see it's so fine See look at that.
It's so fine Told you I told you We're so fine Okay That's right.
They should be fearing me!
Not that, Rocket.
Nice guy.
They should be scared of me!
That's right.
That should go, what's one?
That should go.
What the fuck?
What's one thing you guys are doing good right now?
Um, I'm recruiting the team.
Try to help.
This shit.
I'm blowing people up.
Hell yeah.
I didn't kill people again.
Oh my okay, we have what okay?
I like this positive room.
All right that's a little awkward.
All right We're gonna die to spot you up but that's okay Yep, there it is there it is There it is.
Oh there it is.
Oh there it is At least you survive What you do?
I had a feeling.
Oh, did it work?
I had a feeling I feel it.
Yeah.
Rocket fire right.
We're down only now.
I got Loki.
See?
Whoops.
Oh.
Okay, but who's got me?
Oh my god.
Nobody saved us.
Okay.
That's not on me.
Oh, that is huge.
That is actually huge.
Don't worry.
I'm fucking flying.
Maybe somebody's close to this.
I'm just playing for my life.
I'm walking point now.
Good job, guys.
Keep it up.
Yay!
That's right.
This is my res.
My domain.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'm Kobe.
Okay, watch this.
He's going to destroy it.
He's gonna destroy it.
He's gonna...
Guys, he's destroying it.
Never mind.
No more watch this.
He's gonna destroy it.
Oh, no.
No more watch this.
Yes.
He may or may not have destroyed it.
Oh!
Hello, I am alive.
Alright.
I should have died so we could have our res again.
That is my bad.
Oh.
Oh wait, we gotta kill!
We gotta kill!
Wait, what?
Oh we're going in.
Oh shit, oh shit, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Don't worry.
Nice.
Nice!
He doesn't know, he doesn't know I'm here.
He doesn't know, I'm here.
He doesn't know!
He doesn't know My little red spikens Why is there?
Okay.
There you go.
He only lacks critical information How did they not see me?
I'm a small little guy In this big world The big scary world I'm a menace The quay actually okay well he's not playing rocket anymore this time it's no aim time i'm a little sneaky little guy i cannot see you but it's just very tiny guys honestly i won't be surprised if there's meta with like skins especially like rocket skins where they just get if they see the map they get like the beacon because like each beacon is a different color and then they they choose the rocket where the beacon would blend into the walls i won't be surprised if people do that the fucking actual try-hards because my beacon fucking sucks in the in the summer skin because it's literally bright blue like it's bright blue in the dark I'm like it's like where could the beacon be the bright blue is it the bright blue lava lamp against the dark wall and it glows
Yeah, it's screaming, hitting me.
I think our Spider-Man might be better.
He's gonna grip me, isn't he?
I'm not going straight in yet.
Yeah, I knew it.
I was like, he wanted that grip.
Oh, they're running triple support.
They have Ultron.
I see Ultron.
Oh, no.
I got you, buddy.
That's fine.
It's so...
It's not fine no more.
Oh, they have Penny.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, my God.
She's in the air.
I'm sorry.
That's my bad.
I was like, where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's...
That's my bad.
I need to wait for...
Oh, they're running...
They're running Penny.
So it means I have to...
I have to play Sue.
Yeah, I'm playing Sue.
Because, like, I'm not playing...
I'm not playing Cloak against Penny.
I know what happened.
God damn it.
I know exactly what's gonna happen.
There you go.
Okay.
All right, I gotta care about Luna more.
Come on, I messed...
Come on, he messed up his swing!
We killed Bucky!
I'm a little scared about...
I mean, we could kite that.
Except for our Angela.
Whoa, yeah, except for our...
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, that's fine.
What?
How?
Oh my god.
That's unlucky.
Our Luna got gripped away from my ult.
That's so unlucky.
No, our Luna was outside my ult.
Yeah, that's a... They ran triple support.
What could we do?
Spider-Man is useless against triple.
Like, he can't do anything.
Because they just peel.
There's...
Like, you know, Spider-Man already has to deal with two peelers.
Now the spider-man is dealing with like three people that can that can I can care for each other so it's like yes, it's just unfortunate It's just unfortunate Please save our strange oh my god you're Luna you're fucking crazy Nice There you go all right oh my god please i'm gonna try i don't i can't build all the time oh my god please luna i'm trying so hard to care for you right now guys fight them
fight them please
oh my god I have a
I have to use it's just so we can live that's unlucky I don't think we're winning this guys
oh my god I tried so hard to peel I felt like All I did was peel.
Nothing is that.
Because we're running...
DPS we're running is like...
Like the DPS we're running cannot kill triple support.
These are really good.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
They literally counted our spam, man, because they went triple.
I can't play Rocket because she was on Angela.
There was no reason.
He's like, you guys are really good.
That's so unlucky.
We didn't play anything that counters triple support.
I don't remember what actually, to be fair, I don't even know what counters triple support.
I think you just have, it's like, I think you just play triple support the counter triple support that's like the only way i feel like like it's just whoever team plays the better triple support wins yeah no because the thing is like um people you you just do so much damage but there's never like there's no like follow up follow up there's no like actual uh like you do so much damage but they just heal each other.
Like, what can I do?
What can you do?
They just heal each other.
It's literally like, it's literally just whoever plays the better triple support, but no, none of our teammates wanted to play triple support.
I think it's like, you have to play four DPS, one support, and one tank to beat triple support.
Because you just put so much, you just put so much damage into it, they can't heal it.
There's so much, just like, fucking all that damage in.
Like, what can they do?
You can't out-heal death at that point.
Jeff Nato?
No.
Jeff Nato fucking sucks.
Because Storm sucks.
Storm is only viable against Triple Tank.
Storm just sucks as a character.
Right now.
She wasn't- She wasn't bad before.
Did I have the Moki guy again?
Maybe Namor Hawk?
Namor...
Bruce, maybe.
Hulk, maybe.
Namor Hulk is pretty good.
Not to play Luna.
I don't want to.
I don't want to play Luna.
Get me out.
Back to Luna, jail.
I go.
Wham.
I get GM too.
I might just stop.
Before they take me too deep in.
They have a Jeff.
Who's stream sniping?
Yeah, you fucking stream sniper.
What do I have to give it to?
Whoa.
Alright.
Grab that.
I do want to end top 500 this season.
I want to do it.
Oh, nice.
That's fucking hilarious.
Okay, I'll body block.
There you go.
I bought you out.
That's how you do it, bitch!
That's how you do it!
The fact that I had the body block for you, fuckers oh my god please
i couldn't get in he was still there he was still there i didn't think he was so close to me door stuck door stuck he was i did not I didn't think he was still there.
I was not expecting that.
I thought he was gone.
I was about to jump in too.
That was the worst part.
I was just about to jump in when he came back.
Fucking menace to society.
JJ ate him.
He was right.
He is a criminal.
of spider-man sat behind behind yeah he is behind what the fuck is he doing there I'm just gonna stand there am I dead yes I am yeah well What- what are- what are- what is going on?
We ain't got eaten by- what do you mean?
How do we stop, Jeff?
Like, who's killing us?
Who is killing us?
We literally got eaten by Jeff.
What the fuck does he mean?
Who is killing- did he not see the giant ass fucking shark that ate us?
Like, I'm sorry, but we're playing the same game, right?
the hell look at the hell look at the hell i hope we are i hope okay nice i'm safe for now
oh my god please please get me out of here get me the out of here Thank God.
Let's do it for now.
Please.
See, this is what I'm saying.
The moment... Oh, my God.
This is what I'm saying.
The moment you go triple support, he's actually used this.
Because, like, what can he do?
What?
What can he do?
We just...
We just heal each other.
I swear.
God, get out!
Who did he?
What?
Who did he eat?
I'm so confused.
Who was he?
Yum!
a nice deep freeze okay take those oh we don't take those i i guess okay look at that look at that wow triple support okay
wow die spider-man who do i love first okay uh Oh, okay, I'll go first.
Okay, you can go first.
Yeah, I'll go first.
It's okay.
Wait, can we let Rocky go first actually?
Can we let Rocky go first?
Oh, oh my god.
It's fine.
Look at that.
He's gonna change all!
Yay!
I don't know how.
I saw death in my eyes.
I don't know.
It worked.
We're so healthy.
That was the healthiest I've ever been.
I was one foot on my deathbed.
They were right about to bury me alive before I made a miraculous recovery.
That was very scary.
You think?
Wait.
Oh.
Hello.
Goodbye.
I'll see you.
Hey guys, I lived!
Oh!
Never mind.
Hi, Liv, though.
They did not live.
I was like, hey, guys, I'm back, guys.
What did I miss?
What did I miss, everybody?
They got off.
Yeah, they got off.
They got off triple support.
Look at that.
They got off Spider-Man.
I wish our Spider-Man did that!
Wow!
That's crazy that our Spider-Man didn't do that.
Is that crazy?
What the fuck?
Oh my...
Yo, you can use your sword also.
That's my bad.
I thought we brought it.
I was like, where's my...
Where's my rocket all of it?
Where did it go?
Where's my rocket doing?
I thought my rocket was like my buddy.
I'm goodbye.
Hello, goodbye everybody.
Hello, rocket, please.
Rocket, what?
Goodbye, everyone.
Hello, I'm back.
That's crazy.
He just swam right past 20 of us.
That's actually crazy.
They only have trains.
Lunar first.
It's insane.
Oh my.
We can do it.
It's okay.
Oh, it's no longer okay.
It's no longer...
I was not standing in there.
I'm sorry.
I was not...
There was absolutely no way I was standing in that.
Okay, we're dead.
Wait, how is our rocket still have all?
How does our rocket still have all?
I don't understand.
How does our rocket still have your all?
Time to switch things up.
Yeah, he's been holding all through three fights.
I'm Luna Snow.
like the moon i shine in darkness we're keeping this calm
okay no it's not rocket that's the it's not jeff that's the counter to triple support it was literally their team actually swapped off with spider my team didn't swap off with spider i have to say luna for altron the altron literally cannot play if i don't play luna It's literally our,
our team's just playing triple support wrong because our rocket has never ulted.
Also rocket is not normally not the rocket is normally not the support you play with triple support.
You play Jeff or Jeff Mantis or like literally everything but rocket.
Literally you play you play everything but rocket for triple support is usually Jeff Mantis or Adam.
Jeff Matt.
Yeah.
with it yeah well she did he didn't even oh that's the thing also apparently the left side is troll now you go right you have to heal here left side is troll here nobody stands there anymore
Nokia um Loki works in triple uh if you have Adam um just because like Loki is so bad as a duo support now I just wanted to kill that venom.
Like, fuck that guy in particular.
It was technically a troll using my clap there.
There was no reason to use it.
Also, we did not save any alt for the Jeff up.
Like, we literally, all we did was just, like, we never Jeff ulted them.
Okay.
Oh my god, I tried.
I swear to god.
Nice.
Oh, I missed the freeze.
That's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
Okay, do we have any up for it?
Do we... Oh, do we have... Oh, nice.
See, there you go.
See?
That's how you do it.
Okay, now... Oh, shit!
That was crazy!
Oh my god!
That's actually crazy.
That was insane.
Yeah, I was gonna say, are we really just letting him walk up to me like that?
Oh my god, here you go.
I'm up.
I had to use that.
He's still at Strange Alt, though, so GG's.
Good luck, everyone.
Alright.
I got a little confused because there's so many things on my screen.
so many there's so many things on my screen guys there's there's so many things on my screen i am so confused we don't have ults now we don't have ults that's the bad part
oh my god they have strange out they have strange out i'm scared they have strange out i'm so scared
they have strange out i'm so scared Oh, and they also have this.
Goodbye, this is where I died.
This is where I...
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Yes, thank you.
See, this is how you were supposed to play.
I'll try.
That's basically how you just...
You just...
Why did he go here?
You save your ult for the Jeff look.
He has strange ult, so...
I'm scared.
Only 60 seconds left.
There's no way they don't TP.
I feel like they're going to TP.
They have to be TPing.
Oh, what?
Why did they wait so long?
I had to go.
Put some sand here.
Yo!
Whoa!
I told you, you're left!
Alright, this is where they strange, y'all.
This is where it happens.
This is where...
I told you.
No!
Where do I go?
Wow, we won that.
Where do we go?
I wanted to kill the Luna.
Fear.
There was nowhere to go.
I just had to make sure I wasn't with anyone else.
At least I would.
So I'm still a win.
I was gonna kill her.
And then the mag sucked up my fucking shots.
Literally, she was right in front of me.
She like sucked it up like a greedy...
He like sucked it up like a greedy bitch.
A greedy whore.
God damn.
That's why you got kicked out.
And you gotta live in your own little mutant island.
Wait, what else do I have?
Oh, I have this.
I think Manchester's thing is the new venom.
Guys!
Stop!
Stop fighting!
Peace and peace.
love stop fighting peace and love peace and love everyone
look at that see it works look everyone you missed that bro okay that's that's sad i stood still i that's that's so sad he missed that he that's it no peace and love for it hello oh mantis mantis peace and love whoa yeah girls yeah hello hey
just gotta get a little peep show you know god yeah girl you gotta get a little look before he goes out.
It's a war.
Cat.
He needed the little inspiration.
Bro, he's Peter.
Peter Quill.
That is your step...
No, step... Oh, wait, that is.
That is your half-sister, though.
That's half- inbreeding.
It's not... It's like a little worse.
Sweet home, all of
It's not full inbreeding.
It's half.
It's not any better, but it's half worse.
To keep bullies.
Sweet home space Alabama.
I'm fucking getting it.
Emma out of the game.
Because we don't have anyone that plays Emma.
Might as well.
It's the only way.
That's our Yoshi, folks.
Yeah, it's me.
Oh, my God.
Okay, triple support.
I have to play Luna with this.
Um, I play Luna or Invis.
depends on okay i'm playing this or cloak i don't know what no i'll play cloak fuck it i'll play cloak i was like playing i was playing luna last game this is a no aim game right now
um they just don't know him yeah i'll play this i'll play invis so i can push forward I don't want to aim.
I'm like, I aimed as Luna last game.
So I deserve this.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's pizza.
He's like the highest ranked Blade player, apparently.
I don't know.
Because he like spent last season just fucking playing Blade.
Be a little Elo terrorist.
Yo, I love playing Luna.
Not Luna.
Look, because I'm actually Yeah, I'm actually just slouching right now.
I'm leaning back.
No, I'm not even slouching.
I'm leaning back against my chair Because I just never let go of left leg What the fuck get that guy out of here?
What the fuck get him out of here Get him out of here get out Get out of here What you doing?
Get your ass out of my lobby.
Okay, thank God I went to the play.
I need it.
The thing is, I have to save my...
Oh, man.
I have to save my right click.
Because they're...
They're a dive.
They're playing dive.
No fun.
No fun allowed.
What the fuck about?
Actual.
Actual no fun allowed right now.
all right hey guys oh my god i got one shot comboed by the because of the rocky up that's crazy yeah that that happens um the rocket combo with the magic um is like uh it's like instant instant one hit all right i'm coming back i can hear the spider-man so i'm i'm a little scared
There you go.
I got you.
I'm a hero.
Oh, fuck.
All right.
They're all blinded.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
All right.
I'm a little scared.
Just a little.
Wait, where's our mantis?
Oh, he's going to get spawn camp.
We all know it.
I don't worry.
I got you.
Okay, I have to make sure our Mantis doesn't get spawned camp.
I was a little scared for him.
They have Spider-Man ult, so...
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's not the best.
Wait, how did our Groot get over there?
I'm a little scared.
Oh.
Hello.
I...
Woo!
Um...
Yeah, no, I...
Unless our Jeff had the fucking best all of his life, we were not living that.
Nope.
Uh, is anyone TPing?
Do we have it?
Oh.
No TP.
No TP, apparently.
No, no!
I should have put a clone.
All right, I'm back on clone.
I didn't put a clone.
Oh my gosh, I've been invisible women for this.
Can't get me if I'm over here.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Goodbye.
Get out of here.
Fucking loser.
Oh no, he's getting out.
No, I'm not.
Okay, I could play.
Okay, technically I could play Invis.
I could.
Technically.
Nice.
Is it?
Should I?
Would I?
But like, I had, I played during the last game.
I did my, I did my job.
Oh, he's fine.
All right.
Whoa, who is he messing?
Who is he trying to mess with?
Guess we'll never know.
I guess.
Damn.
Don't mess with Pooh again?
Who?
Not quite.
Oh shit, fuck.
Let's use everything!
Fuck it!
Yay!
You know what, I just felt like, yeah, you know, usually, usually I'd be like, hey, I'll first, but I felt, I felt so quirky.
Everyone press Q.
Yeah, um, that's a little awkward.
Oops.
That's not what was supposed to happen.
That is.
We were like, what if we all just press Q?
Like, what would happen if, you know?
What could happen?
Oh, nice.
That was a nice little, actually.
That was insane.
Oh, look, the Spider-Man swapped out.
Yeah, see?
Not so fun now.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, see?
Not so fun.
That took you, right?
That's right.
Fucking sucks, doesn't it?
Oh.
That guy definitely has a...
Who wants to do something?
Oh my god.
Goodbye, everybody.
That's their turn.
Now they press everything.
Yeah, I know.
That was, like, five volts.
Did they use Moon Knight?
I don't know.
I know they used Punisher.
Strange.
uh that's crazy all right it's okay we still have our cues oh nice don't worry that's somewhere yeah see i knew it aim that's somewhere i think i think i think i hit something huge that's right I could be that.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
I hate random bullshit, time.
It's the worst.
Yeah.
This game is so easy.
So easy when you don't have to aim.
Yay!
I love your hate!
Hate only makes me stronger.
Real.
I can only get stronger.
The more I hate.
Keep hating.
I only hate watch.
Yippee!
That's exactly right.
Hate fuels me.
It makes me strong.
Give in to the hate.
Do it.
Alright, here you go.
If they play close...
Oh, there's Penny.
Okay, they have a Penny.
I don't know if I should play close.
I...
Okay, give me a sec.
I swap.
I ain't, I ain't playing that.
I'm not playing that.
There's no reason.
Yeah, I'm not dealing with that.
Like, I'm not crazy.
Yeah.
I like that shit.
Fuck that.
See, that could have been me, guys.
That could have been me.
Yeah, I was gonna say I'm not dealing with the penny mines there.
I'm not dealing with the penny mines.
Oh my god, they're running.
I should have went ultra.
I can't go ultra because we don't have Luna.
There we go.
oh my god please
there's a rocket over there
hello is everything okay because i'm i'm so confused i feel like i feel like there's so many things around me going on right now i don't know out I'm backing out oh that's fucking right she's why are you here I can't raise now oh my god that's fine you know what I have res guys guys okay i have to play luna fuck this fuck this i actually have to play luna because i'm not playing cloak against uh against that no help no help
what was that good question Okay, I have to...
It's unlucky.
Jesus Christ.
Nice.
I'm scared of just the mines.
That's it.
I need to try to make sure I don't...
I don't stand on the mines.
There we go.
I'll push.
Oh, he went the other way.
Oh,
that's right, bitch.
Get edged.
But, like, parable rivals first.
Okay, guys, guys.
Guys, I just realized what I said.
But, like, in-game, in-game, in-game, esport terms.
All three of us stand there.
We should be fine.
Yay!
No, it's not November yet.
End game, end game.
Alright, I think I need one more.
Alright?
I just need one more, and then I'm GM too.
One more!
And then the last streak starts here.
It's always when the closest you are, the harder you fall.
all right give me a sec i gotta pee i'll be back don't worry i got you it's dessert time
this is why you watch my content this is the real show this is this is the real show not not the fucking gameplay yeah i get it i got you guys i know what you're into
One may feel empathy for an enemy and still destroy them.
I think Mantis is like the new Venom.
Venom is now a dying species.
The twerking Venom.
Hello everyone!
Hello!
Oh!
That's right.
I steal your man.
That's right, he ain't moving.
Yeah.
That's okay.
Oh shit.
Whoa.
Damage.
It's like, oh shit.
Hey, do you have it?
I'm not kidding.
Wait, I don't play volleyball.
What?
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, I have that too.
Watch this.
Double volleyball.
Come on, who wants to go?
Come on.
yay oh did i miss wait you have to you have to bounce back
oh no wait i got this i got this okay how do i hit it whoops i gotta leave i know i gotta leave i didn't realize you can hit back i thought it was auto I...
Run.
I thought it was auto!
I didn't know I had to manually hit back!
It's okay, I ran away.
They'll never find me.
I ran away.
There's so many Angela's.
Didn't even know it was fucking dog shit.
They'll never know.
Who am I going to banish this match?
I ran away.
They'll never know what I did.
Torch.
Oh, bucky.
In before they ban Torch too.
Yeah!
And then I'll ban Emma.
I'll ban Emma.
Just because we have...
We're running...
mag, Angela.
It's only natural.
Bum, bum, bum.
But I don't...
We both had the same idea.
That means both teams are not playing Emma.
Both teams didn't want to play Emma then.
I don't know.
I have to play.
I don't know for this.
I guess I'll give it to Panther.
No, she's not...
I don't think she's good in higher, Elo.
I personally don't think so.
But in this...
Elo, technically...
It's still the Wild Wild West, technically.
Because of the Rank Reset.
The Rank Reset just makes this the Wild Wild West.
No, I'm dual Doom Keeling.
It's still Doom Keeling.
But it's just a duo of Doom Q.
Yay.
Where's my dancing mode?
Why is there no dancing mode for Luna?
She's literally an idol.
I have a DJ.
That's actually crazy now that I think about it.
She's an idol and yet she doesn't have a dancing mode.
Yeah, but I want to dance when I don't have a...
What if I just want to dance?
Am I not allowed to just dance?
Why is my dancing paywalled?
I don't like that my invis is like so deep in.
What is that rock?
Oh my god, that rocket was fucking god, I was gonna say.
What is my mag doing?
What is she doing?
Okay, I'm a little concerned because our mag just played ultra high grass.
Like, I got, I was confused.
I was like, the entire team is below.
She's a pro.
She doesn't dance for free.
True.
That's why, yeah, that's why I want to pay for you.
I want to pay so I can pay so I can't I feel like I might oh my gosh my Invis is not I'm trying to play with my Invis as much as I can because like I'm
scared oh my god oh my god please
someone help us I swear to God the Invis and I I'm sorry, Infus dropped down.
Oh my god.
He just walked up to us.
Alright, that's fine.
I was gonna say, why the fuck did we just let him do that?
I'm sorry.
It's fine, we got him.
They have Penny ult, though.
That...
Okay.
That, okay.
We'll take it.
I'm a little scared.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, I just made it.
Alright, but I don't know we can live through that.
Okay, I slowly back the way.
I'm slowly back.
Oh my god.
My god, I'm clapping.
I'm clapping.
I'm clap.
I don't know what else I could do.
I clap.
Okay, um Hmm
Um Clap and I clap the way Clapy, clapy.
Alright, now we have one thing.
I don't even know what to...
I looked at my chat.
I can't justify it.
I was looking at my chat there.
Oh my god, my Invis was in front of me.
That was my bad.
I should maybe pay attention.
No, I think I think this is maybe a Chichiko next.
Just a maybe.
I think maybe the enemy team is a little better than us.
Just just a little bit.
I can't play Cloak because they wouldn't go Penny.
I can't play it.
It's literally Luna's Invisory Cloak.
I'm Luna snow like the moon I shine we could play triple We could Triple support is the only thing I can think of that might work Why the fuck are you playing Iron Man if you're gonna play Iron Man just play ultra Like literally if you're gonna play trip if you're gonna play Iron Man,
you know what's like Iron Man and also does heals and damage like ultra Please don't there's no way I can do this without him
That's literally all we have to do.
I got a sip in time.
Should be fine.
Ultroner is literally better Ironman.
Why would you be willing to play Ironman when you could just play Ultron?
He's literally the perfect being.
That's why it doesn't make sense.
Why play this when you can play a better character?
You're saying he didn't get that?
Why is our arm man there?
Oh, shit.
Why was I there?
Okay.
I'm so paranoid when I see the web.
I feel like the web traps are right there.
I literally was like, hey, guys.
Hey, what are you guys doing?
What are you guys doing over there, huh?
You having fun?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay, this is like...
I don't know.
I'm trying.
Like, yeah, there's...
Yeah.
Yeah, um...
Um...
I'm not out healing that.
Uh...
Yeah, no, there's...
There's no out...
There's no out heals for that.
You have to use Invis to out heal it.
There was no outplay ability.
I mean, we stalled it.
I used it to stall.
Yeah, like, he was not living through an Invis Punisher.
It's literally...
The only way is literally just Invis.
My ult doesn't clear that.
My ult cannot heal that.
Which is unfortunate.
Oh shit, nice.
He has up.
He's looking for it.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Oh shit, there it is.
How is he in there?
oh wait how how how was he in this in there I'm actually so confused I don't know how he got there I was like what the fuck who's over there like who is that what the fuck was that
I got this
lucky all right does that hit anything like what does that hit
oh my god oh my god i'm i'm doing my best to keep you up i'm doing my best but this is where we die too this is actually where we die This is actually where we die
Yeah, very real Barely felt like we had an Iron Man.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm saying if we're gonna play Iron Man Just play ultra Then my court I was too close.
They were like you had you had it too good for too long
Yeah.
Yeah, why don't you just play the better Iron Man?
Alright.
Let us avoid the Iron Man.
Huh?
I don't know what I'm streaming for.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Either hit GM too, or I hit 4 hours.
I'm done.
I'm EP now.
I mean, I was EP when I started.
Yeah, it's only two games.
Then it'll be three games.
Then four games, guys.
When will it stop?
That's crazy.
I've been the only Venom in all these Doom matches.
What happened to our society?
I don't want to live in a society when I'm the only twerking Venom.
What's the point?
Wait, what's the point?
That...
hello ma'am oh you're oh no what will i do i'm getting brainwashed by him what will i do i'm tricking venom is a dying piece of art oh no not the mind control oh no i'm doing this not oh yes nice yet yes right make it rain i don't do this for free i'm oh no i'm twerking against my will there's the so funny mind control is this what happens is this what they mean is this oh shit hello mag it's your turn I heard,
I heard it's someone's special birthday.
I heard, am I mad?
Come on, I heard it's someone's special birthday.
Toki.
Damn, she's laughing for real.
That's right, happy birthday, sir.
Oh wait, you know what I'm gonna do?
What?
This is why I've been waiting for this entire day.
That's harassment.
Finally, I found someone using that emote.
I've been waiting my whole life for that emote.
The last thing he saw before I got snapped out of existence.
This is the last thing he sees not the type who fades quietly into the background now Who am I gonna banish from this match?
I'm a menace that's right instead of finding pictures of spider-man you should have caught me I'm the true menace here
Think oh my god, we're not winning this our only tank is on Thor
I have like very low hopes on this lobby
GG's and pizza I don't know pizza pizza usually don't play tank unless he decides to be quirky today
all right I'm not playing Luna Luna Mantis or I'm not doing that
hey guys Don't worry, I've got you, guys.
Don't worry.
We got this, guys.
I'm here, the solo support.
Extraordinary.
On defense.
Okay, we're not...
Okay, that's fine.
We'll just grab your armor.
Grab your armor first.
Sport key.
Can you play tank or support?
completely other room all right grab your army actually we can grow we can go actually rocket rocket cloak actually works rocket tank actually works i'm not rocket cloak we got too many tanks three What do you mean too many tanks?
We have one tank.
When did one became too many?
When...
What do you mean?
That's one...
I'm sorry.
Did we all forget how to count?
It's that...
Did we all forget how to count, guys?
That is one too many dookies.
Silly.
No, apparently...
Rocket...
Your defense on this is really...
Rocket and Cloak for this is really good.
One more minute.
I have to take that away.
That's unlucky.
Let's hope nobody dies.
I don't have Wes.
Oh, that's unlucky.
That's unlucky.
I still don't have Ress.
Ow.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, they just walked up to me.
All right.
I kept pushing forward.
Time for Invis.
Because I'm wolf.
I was gonna play Invis anyway.
I mean, I'm still gonna get fucking work my wolf.
Oh.
Let's hope that this works
All right
That's fine.
I got you.
Okay, not that though I'm trying I'm trying
Okay, they're also running solo Alright.
Okay.
That would be cool.
That's nice.
They're also...
Oh.
That's unlucky.
I have to use that so I can live.
Jesus Christ okay I have to use that so I can live
Oh he bubbled it that's unlucky I have to use it Where did he go where did he go
He jumps so high, I don't even know.
Where did he go?
I was like, he like, he like did a fucking magic trick or some shit.
Like, what the fuck?
He actually disappeared in my own ult.
In my ult.
How do you disappear in my ult?
That's crazy.
At least our authority.
player is willing to be a little flexible oh my okay i i don't know what i can do i don't know what i can do to save him yeah there we run we run we keep running i i ran so far oh no oh no there you just run that's unlucky I was I'm a little scared here though not gonna lie I got blinded so oh my god he lives
okay I saw that mag you don't think I saw that but I saw that Mac, Mac, that, go back, go back to, you might need to go back to basketball training.
I, that,
you might, you might have to go and get a coach for basketball, bro.
I had, that was a little embarrassing.
We all saw.
I don't have a triple right now.
I'm at 50.
They're taking damage.
They're going triple tank?
Fucking nerds.
I'm at 70 here.
Back up, back up, web, nothing and all that.
Yeah, back, back, back, back.
I don't have anything.
All right.
That's unlucky.
We die.
I'll die here.
So a TP?
We have to TP you.
I don't know if he can.
There you go.
Oh.
Nice, nice.
He used it late.
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
Oh my god, this... We're not winning this fight, by the way.
We're...
Okay.
We're absolutely not winning this fight.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
That's unlucky.
Hey guys!
I think it's time to play Storm.
Bye.
Angus, you need to cross me on the fake game.
What did he say?
I don't even know he said.
I waited in the fade What the fuck does he mean I stood there waiting for you And I'll fade How do I What do you mean like trust you I literally was with you They have Luna here We don't have any support Keep that in mind
How do I trust you more I already stood still the god of thunder i trusted you i trusted you you told me to trust you with the fade i trusted you he's not giving me office by the way i'm sure it's working he said trust you on the fade and this is why i don't trust god do i have to play luna i don't want to play luna like how my half dude god damn it
okay that's crazy i am ready to put on the show Alright.
I had to do that because I was scared.
I heard...
Oh my gosh.
I got hit!
Goodbye!
Oh my god, I hit.
Alright.
Do I have Bucky?
No.
It's surprising.
We don't do any of the triple tank counties.
Okay.
Oh my god, I can't do anything.
I thought someone else could be on the cart.
The thing is, Thor is...
Oh wait, he had to.
He had... we literally had no shield tanks.
We have zero shield tanks.
Fine, I'll play Luna.
Fine.
I'll play Luna.
I shine in darkness.
guess i guess i'll play luna really loki luna no he's not even meta i don't know he's just so weak
fine i'll do it i'll go to luna jail i knew it guys i knew it the moment i'm close the moment i'm close to the gm2 they give me all the terrorists the terrorists all show up Oh, spare me your heroic platitudes, brother.
It's always been that way.
Well, to be fair, the only DPS that's doing anything is Sporky Cat, to be fair.
I'll do it, but I'm not gonna be...
I just got really bored with Luna.
Because last season, it was literally Luna Loki every game.
Like, if you want to win, you have to play Luna Loki.
you could play so I of course I got bored because there was no variety it's legit you have to play if you don't you're actually throwing so I got like super bored with it hey can we kill that one spider-man there the spider girl hey he's over it okay I kill him It's okay.
I can do it.
But I can't.
The scooter.
Sorry, scooter woman.
My apologies.
I meant scooter woman.
I'm just... So like, you know, I'm just trying to enjoy the freedom, you know?
Of playing like all... Because this season, it's like the most flexibility I've ever seen for supports.
Because it's like literally support meta.
Doesn't mean it's the best, but because triple support is so boring, but like It's something, you know Can we push?
Can we push a bit?
I'm trying.
I'm sorry.
I'm very slow Mentally right in
And physically Luna can't really do much because I need like there a mana for him i'm gonna try and i'm gonna get luna all out all right actually maybe my brain my brain isn't working he wants the damage boost dragon on niche dragon on niche
stands down we definitely did not need that
hello get out of here We're in herdy.
Wow.
It is so hard to get me on her face, right?
But maybe...
Yes, it is.
Oh, yes.
That's...
I think that's karma.
That may or may not be karma right there.
That's...
to a karma.
Oh, there he is.
Cool.
Going on chaos.
Fuck.
This is not good.
I may be using everything there.
Okay, this is bad because, no, it's not nice because I froze the strange, which means he has 50% alt so he can still use it.
strange but got console so at 50 they use yeah he says it on 50 that's the thing that's why it's not good what the what the what the was that luna doing we're gonna have the force on oh what the okay that sucks
maces maybe win over but i don't know if you want to
Are we up to this then?
We get a pair out of this.
Alright, we have...
Heals.
He's gonna all...
Wait, who died?
I was like...
Who is it?
Who died?
Did he...
Oh my god, he got solo a bit.
That's unfortunate.
I was so confused.
I was like, who was that?
Phoenix, Phoenix, Phoenix.
There you go.
Oh, Phoenix, right?
Wait, what?
Where's the Phoenix?
Oh my god, I'm scared.
Phoenix is still behind, by the way.
I don't know where she is.
She's right behind me, isn't she?
I'm so scared.
What?
Where is she?
Oh, no.
Hey, there she is.
Oh, that's unlucky.
That was a little too slow.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not good.
We're getting pummeled.
the other support are getting pummeled in the back.
Like, look at this.
Look, look at us.
That's three takes.
That's all three takes.
That's all three takes just beating us up.
I was like, I don't like that.
That was not fun.
It's just us.
It's like, don't come to this street neighbor again.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, I have love, but everyone's seeing so much damage, man.
Holy shit, we find...
Alright.
Luna, Luna, Luna.
Okay.
all right just so he lit oh my god this is this is not we're not living this we're not living this yeah um you go for four now by the way i've still got songs to sing
That we ain't living that I'm gonna go home.
I might as well go name.
Where?
Oh
my god, Hulk.
Oh my god, Hulk, please Hulk, please
Okay, we do not okay.
We don't kill him.
That's fine Is that true?
Okay, guys, I don't think this is winnable no more.
I want to believe I really do want to believe.
I had a feeling it was over
my bad for the attitude yeah we just they just somehow went from one tank player to three why the fuck did that guy never swapped the tank why did he play iron man wait a minute this guy couldn't play tank this entire time.
He was the Iron Man player.
This fucker.
This actual fucker.
He is a menace.
Someone get him out of here.
Alright.
Okay.
If we lose the next game, I'm still out.
Because it's the four hour mark.
This is...
Next game is my LG.
No matter win loss.
This is my LG.
No matter what.
What the fuck is Ryan, man?
I'm so people on my list.
Everybody changed their names all the time.
Who's Ryan, man?
Oh, that's Super Gomez's alt account.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I know he's, like, trio stacking with TTK.
Because I was like, who the fuck is that guy?
Today is my off.
Today is my off day.
I get to the side when I stop.
This is literally doing overtime.
This is literally my overtime day.
I'm literally doing overtime.
And all I get are like, Ilo Terrace.
That's my reward for it.
And what the fuck did we get?
Oh, this is...
What did we get?
We have two players on our team that's top 500.
Two players on the enemy team that's top 500.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Maybe good?
I don't know.
Alright.
I banned Emma.
in case they do torch first ban
you're right I should have stopped while I'm ahead you're so right guys
alright while they're doing oh nice they banned torch for me that's good oh but do we have any Phoenix players no right I'm banning Phoenix then yeah I'm not dealing with Phoenix I just had a Phoenix last game I'm done already
Daisy, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
All right.
What map is this?
Hell is Haven?
I'll go, Cloak.
We are Cloak and Dagger.
We are hope and fear.
All right, Luna.
I'm allowed to play Cloak.
Last game I played, Luna.
This is my no aim game.
Okay.
I don't like any of the...
I think the only cloak skin I like is the Battle Pass one.
The one where she's like...
I don't like that one either.
Honestly, like...
Oh, I didn't...
I don't like the Phoenix.
There's a Phoenix one.
I actually like the Phoenix skin for it.
Only because...
I hate the skin.
But I like the sound effects.
Because it does...
It makes the sound effect when this hits people.
So I know if I hit someone.
Like, the Phoenix one lets me know if I healed someone with my E.
Like, it makes a bling sound.
But this one doesn't.
This one, like, is just, like, guess.
Figure it out yourself.
Oh, running trip?
Okay, we're gonna run trip.
Fuck, I should play Duna then.
Are we running trip?
Are they also running trip?
Oh, Nishias!
I don't want to use my right click yet.
I'll use it here, actually.
Just use it here.
Oh, don't worry, Jeff.
I got you.
Don't worry, I got you.
Don't worry.
Oh, that's very unlucky.
That's very unlucky.
only because like we have one tank they have two not great for us because i have a feeling what's gonna happen i knew it guys remember i was like we came so far and then they're just gonna take it away they have two tanks we have one it truly is sad because triple support only works oh my god have ultron as the other triple support only works if you also have uh oh my god you're crazy i i couldn't fade i couldn't fade in time goodbye everybody no i was on cloak i was on cloak i mean i was on dagger and not cloak that's so sad my time to shine lights out i'm sad i was on the wrong wrong one.
Okay, she has to do it.
There.
Oh.
Hello, I'm here.
Hello.
Thank you.
I'm a little scared.
Oh my god.
Are they alive?
They are.
Okay.
Alright.
That's good.
Thank God we have.
Thank God we have that up.
Wait, I feel like there's a...
Something doesn't feel right here.
Yeah, could someone else go check that over there real quick?
There's also a Jeff over there too.
Thank you.
Alright, that's cool.
I'm just trying to make sure that that's man goodbye jeff what man you know what'd be cool right about now you don't um that's awkward that's he uh jeff ulceded the pit um so yeah He ulted at- I think he wanted to do a fast drop but like he fucked up.
He fucked up the fast drop.
I don't think like that's what he wanted to do.
This.
He lives though?
That fucking sucks.
I can't believe he lives.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew it.
You can feel it.
gets the has to have this oh that's unlucky oh my i don't know this is winnable
you know what fuck it let's go oh this is not winnable now bye that's not that's okay we still have mantis oh you know i thought i mantis would all but i guess not I Rished it I knew you would I got the mag all out though.
I was like debating like okay mag all it's gone though That's fine.
I risked it Yep, I did use everything I wanted to I was debating I was like okay I blind him All right, that's fine oh that's fine where am i i this is not fine oh my god oh my god what what hit me
oh my god that was a quick okay i will say i'll keep it i will say that that um until the trick is played on them i will say that was a really good uh that was a really good shot from him what yeah the map move the map move that's crazy why do you know how's the guy alive
I'm alive.
I barely processed the fact that, like, I got my TP out in time.
Holy shit.
I was like, please tell me my clone is still there.
I'm so happy.
I literally thought my clone would have been destroyed.
I was, like, ready.
I was ready for it.
Okay, uh, I think I should go up.
I do go with Cloak.
They have Cloak.
I'm surprised the Cloak.
Yeah, me too.
I didn't think my clone was still alive.
I was like, please, please tell me he's still alive, please.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All right, wee.
Wee.
Oh, they're captain.
See, this is why.
Oh, no.
Nice.
I got you!
I got you, Jeff!
I'm never gonna quit you and he's slowly walking back you got this Jeff he's just slowly he's just slowly walking he was like is he still there Jeff please I'm so scared for you I'm so never gonna give you up I ain't never gonna quit you Jeff you're scaring me you're literally You're really scaring me.
Wait, blows first.
Oh, you can.
Okay.
Alright.
What?
Okay.
okay I mean that's fine I'm just like wait I was like where what was that yeah I know I was like what happened what the fuck is going on I don't know this game is weird like what happened they were so like coordinated what happened to the scheme Like,
what happened?
I was...
Okay, I'll do it.
You got shields?
Oh yeah.
Hello.
Hey, there's a little guy.
Hey, hey there little guy.
Hey!
Oh shit!
Goodbye.
Wait, there's a captain America here.
There you go.
I leave.
Oh my god.
We good.
I'm fine.
Yay!
We did it.
We end on a win.
Easy game.
We might not have got GM2 today, but like, I'm okay.
K-Wave win.
We're technically positive.
We're up, like, three games.
After four hours.
I take those.
We're up four games after four hours, you know?
Alright.
GG's.
Alright, I'm gonna head off now.
No stream tomorrow.
I'm chilling tomorrow.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the raid, Rosa.
Unfortunately, I'm ending.
Sorry.
No.
I streamed four hours today.
Eepie.
But now your curse is gone.
So you can win.
But thank you all for watching.
Thank you guys.
For those who are new here.
My name is Doki Bear.
I usually stream more on YouTube.
So please check me out there.
Exclamation point socials.
Also before I go.
I'm going to do a little shilling real quick.
Because there's three days left of the pre-order.
yes so I have an apparel collection out right now with Gina draws so please check out the apparel collection because in three days it's gone forever so check it out they're all really really cute they're not like super like you know vtuber centric um it's like you can wear these out in public and no one knows that you're no one knows you're a dragon you know other than the bag maybe but uh you can bet all these items individually um but I hope you guys uh check collab merch uh because in three days it'll be gone um other than that uh everyone why uh you want to follow me on twitter uh that's when i usually announce whenever i go live on twitch uh so yeah check me on twitter as well and subscribe to my youtube because i usually stream over there i do gorilla streams on twitch most of the time um so it's very sporadic but i still have a good time with you guys hey guys as always everybody stay oh yeah and go support me via other means i also have a merch store dokeymerch.com exclamation
point merch and you can check out my merch as well a lot of ways to support me and guys i'll check you out i'll check you guys out later i mean uh i'm gonna head out now i think my brain is fried right now i played a lot of rivals as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flow and you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it see i can't believe it the moment i turned on my stream everybody it i swear to god i had like two i had two games back to back where i was just getting yelled at by children and now i turned on stream four hours nobody yelled at me fucking pussies that's right fucking if you guys yell at me do it on stream i want to farm you stop being doing it off stream because i still remember your name it doesn't matter if it's on or off stream i will remember stream i am that spiteful i might look crazy right now but i am that spiteful hey guys i'll see you guys later bye guys bye